bonjour merci de nous rejoindre sur
Public Sénat pour la suite cet
après-midi de la discussion autour du
projet de loi sur la réforme
territoriale les sénateurs arrivent cet
après-midi sur l'article premier de ce
texte et là nous sommes au cœur de ce
projet de loi puisque c'est l'article
premier du texte et bien qui redéfinit
le découpage des régions françaises
alors vous allez le voir il va y avoir
beaucoup de prise de parole dans un
premier temps des sénateurs sur cet
article premier plus d'une heure et
demie de prise de parole et puis dans un
second temps et bien les sénateurs vont
examiner trois amendements importants
puisqu'il s'agit de trois amendements de
suppression de cet article premier du
projet de loi des amendements qui ont
été déposés par les groupes centrist les
radicaux de gauche et également les
communistes pourquoi ils demandent la
suppression de cet article premier vient
tout simplement parce qu'ils estiment
que le gouvernement a été trop vite dans
la redéfinition des régions française
donc il est vraisemblable que cet
article premier va tomber cet après-midi
au Sénat et que donc à l'issue de la
discussion sur l'ensemble du projet de
loi et bien le texte repartira à
l'Assemblée nationale sans redéfinition
des régions françaises en fait les
sénateurs comptent sur la deuxième
lecture qui arrivera à l'automne après
les élections sénatoriales de septembre
et bien pour revoir tranquillement ils
ont besoin de temps c'est ce qu'ils vont
dire en séance cet après-midi vous allez
l'entendre ils ont besoin de temps les
sénateurs pour revoir cette carte se
redécoupage des régions françaises donc
tout de suite direction l'hémicycle du
Sénat on fera un point en fin de journée
à 19h dans 24 heures semaine avec
Delphine Girard sur cette discussion à
tout à l'heure mes chers collègues nous
reprenons la suite de la discussion du
projet de loi relatif à la délimitation
des régions aux élections régionales et
départementales et modifiant le
calendrier électoral dans la discussion
des articles que nous sommes parvenus à
l'article 1er sur cet article premier la
parole est tout d'abord à Fabienne
Keller
monsieur le Président messieurs les
ministres monsieur le rapporteur de la
commission spéciale chers collègues nous
voilà à l'examen de l'article 1er du
projet de loi dont l'objectif est de
réduire le nombre des régions ce texte
fait référence au Comité pour la réforme
territoriale le rapport d'Édouard
Balladur de 2009 et aussi au rapport de
Jean-Pierre Raffarin et divertinger
publié il y a un an
et pourtant les éléments de fond qui
composent la matière de ces deux
rapports de ces éléments de fond rien
n'est repris rien sur les compétences
territoriales rien sur le nécessaire
maintien des départements et de la
proximité en particulier pour les zones
peu denses rien sur la concertation
indispensable pour construire ces
grandes régions
au fond il n'est pas question d'une
réforme qualitative
il n'est pas question de doter les
régions de réelles compétences et d'un
redécoupage cohérent non ce texte ne
poursuit en fait qu'un seul et unique
objectif réduire le nombre de régions et
si je peux me permettre monsieur le
ministre de résumé votre stratégie en
paraprasant Alfred de Musset je dirais
qu'importe les régions pourvu qu'on ait
la baisse
et nous voilà face à un tableau abrupte
pour lequel aucune des questions de
fonds des traité
pas d'études ni d'analyse des faits sur
les stratégies économiques et sociales
communes pas d'études ni d'analyse sur
la cohérence des réseaux de transport
rien sur les convergences les
complémentarités économiques pas
d'analyse des flux et des dynamiques
universitaires ou encore de la création
culturelle ou des échanges et des
dynamiques culturelles comme René Paul
Savary la bien rappelé tout à l'heure
rien non plus sur les recommandations
des territoires et des acteurs locaux le
redécoupage est ainsi dénué de vision
stratégiques il est demandé au
territoire de sunir sans qu'aucune
perspective claire ne soit établie et
qu'il donne du sens à une telle union en
somme chers collègues à défaut d'un
mariage d'amour le gouvernement ne nous
donne même pas les raisons permettant
d'accepter un mariage de raison
mes collègues l'ont très bien exprimé
dans le cadre de la discussion générale
le gouvernement nous propose cette
réflexion de fond plus tard au moment de
l'examen du deuxième texte c'est
notamment la question des compétences
mais je voudrais quand même ici
illustrer l'incroyable faiblesse de
l'étude d'impact la seule et unique page
évoquant la fusion de l'Alsace et de la
Lorraine
page 41 il y a trois petits paragraphes
qui expliquent sommairement le
bien-fondé d'une telle union on y
apprend ainsi que l'Alsace et la
Lorraine sont deux régions frontalières
le même argument chers collègues aurait
justifié le rapprochement de Rhône-Alpes
avec Provence-Alpes-Côte d'Azur
de la Lorraine avec Champagne-Ardenne
ou de l'Aquitaine avec Midi-Pyrénées
en somme un argument bien faible qui
vient justifier en 8 petites lignes le
rapprochement entre l'Alsace et la
Lorraine
mais ne nous y trompons pas si
l'argument frontalier est utilisé dans
ce cas précis je sais que cher collègue
vos régions ne sont pas mieux lotis et
les raisons qui sont avancées pour
justifier leur redécoupage ne sont guère
mieux argumentés
et puis il y a les régions qui ont de la
chance
celles qui n'ont pas subi de redécoupage
territorial
c'est cette perspective que nous
souhaitons pour l'Alsace et que nous
défendrons avec de nombreux collègues si
l'occasion nous en est donnée à travers
un amendement
préservant son intégrité territoriale
nous défendons cet amendement car à
l'image de l'accord ou de la Bretagne
l'Alsace est une un territoire avec une
identité forte elle est aussi dotée d'un
droit local auquel les Alsaciens sont
très attachés
cette singularité crée une cohérence
territoriale forte ce sentiment d'être à
la fois pleinement alsacien et
pleinement français
nous défendrons cet amendement car il y
a pas de raison que ce qui se justifie
d'un côté pour la Bretagne la Corse mais
aussi les Pays de Loire l'Aquitaine PACA
qui reste inchangé
ne soit pas utilisé pour d'autres et que
l'Alsace soit fusionné contre son gré
Blaise Pascal disait vérité en deçà des
Pyrénées erreur au-delà nous sommes bien
tous du même côté des Pyrénées et cette
vérité doit s'appliquer de la même
manière à toutes les régions
un mot sur la question du chef-lieu la
proposition de fusion entre l'Alsace et
la Lorraine pose également comme dans
toutes les régions nouvellement
constituées la question du chef-lieu la
détermination du chef-lieu d’une région
est fondamentale et évidemment pour
Strasbourg capitale européenne elle est
stratégique Strasbourg la seule
métropole du nord-est de la France j'y
viens en cohérence avec les cons le
travail qui a été fait ici au Sénat avec
les orientations du texte de loi je
demande que si d'aventure la fusion de
l'Alsace et de la Lorraine nous était
imposées Strasbourg soit désigné comme
chef-lieu voilà chers collègues quelques
réflexions à l'ouverture de ce débat sur
l'article 1 là où l'intérêt général eu
commandé des études d'impact bien
construites une concertation large
permettant de dégager ce qui fait
consensus de ce qui fait encore débat de
préparer un débat de qualité pour la
nécessaire évolution de l'organisation
territoriale
et bien nous faisons face à un tableau
mal préparé et malétayer cette réforme
mais nécessaire les Français les
représentants des territoires ils sont
prêts et chers collègues pardonnez-moi
comme beaucoup d'entre vous je vous
propose de ne pas adopter une telle
réforme mal construite et mal engagée je
vous remercie merci merci cher collègue
j'ai eu beaucoup de plaisir à accueillir
Fabienne Keller à cette tribu de mais je
vous signale que vous pouvez aussi vous
exprimer des micros qui sont dans la
salle et donc je passe la parole à Yves
Ponzo di Borgo
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
applaudissent et Fabienne puis
laissez-moi parler après merci
monsieur le ministre vous avez rappelé
en commission que votre objectif est
bien de rendre nos régions plus fortes
et plus compétitive afin de s'adapter à
la mondialisation enfin d'être en phase
avec les grandes régions européennes et
mondiales à l'image du landéralement
vous avez affirmé ce découpage
privilégie la taille et les enjeux
économiques je regrets d'ailleurs cet
élément n'apparaisse pas dans l'exposé
des motifs du texte que vous nous
proposez
nous pouvons en regardant la nouvelle
carte proposée par la plupart des
régions que la plupart des régions
sont taillés pour affronter la
concurrence économique européenne même
si pour certaines d'entre elles leur
action déborde de l'Europe pour vers le
monde pour ne pas prendre l'exemple d'un
région Rhône-Alpes qui est à Shanghai ou
de la région Alsace qui est jumelée avec
un
mais une seule région et de la taille
mondiale pour affronter des filles
économiques mondiaux c'est de France
et derrière tout cela ce profil débat
sur les villesmons le débat sur le Grand
Paris
au Sénat nous avons eu une commission
sur le Grand Paris et de très longs
débats sur la région Île-de-France la
loi du 3 juin 2010 relative au Grand
Paris soit Grande Boucle des transports
parisiens constitué le premier pas pour
accompagner conforter les pôles
stratégiques d'Île-de-France et assurer
le développement économique de la France
la loi du 27 janvier 2014 relative à la
modernisation de l'action publique
territoriale d'affirmation des
métropoles aboutit à la création de la
métropole du Grand Paris qui est une
avancée mais très imparfaite
en arrière fond du débat sur le Grand
Paris il y a un débat sur les limites de
ce Grand Paris cela n'a pas encore été
tranché pour certains le Grand Paris
doit se limiter à Paris et ces trois
départements périphériques
le texte la métropole a donné la
possibilité d'élargir le Grand Paris aux
limites des cas départements dans Paris
pour d'autres dont je suis je crois
aussi Monsieur caoutchi Le Grand Paris
doit être la région Île-de-France
entière pour ne prendre qu'un exemple
par l'étranger le grand Moscou c'est 4
fois la région Île-de-France
en 2012 Île-de-France demeure la
première région importante et
sportatrice de bien avec plus d'un
cardes d'importation et 18% des
exportations nationales en valeur
deuxième plateforme fluviale d'Europe
dotée d'infrastructure ferroviaire qu'il
a relié aux grandes capitales
européennes l'Île-de-France est
également située au carrefour des
échanges européens et mondiaux et la
première région économique française est
l'une des premières au niveau européen
l'Ile-de-France contribue pour 29% au
produit intérieur brut métropolitain
seul 22% sont utilisés par les
Franciliens le reste est redistribué
dans les autres régions
ceci grâce notamment l'importation de
nombreux entreprises françaises mais
aussi étrangères et la deuxième région
en Europe et la première en France en
matière d'accueil des investissements
étrangers la troisième dans le monde
derrière l'onde qui a 3 fois plus
qu'elle d'accueil étrangers et New York
à deux fois plus qu'elle sans oublier
qu'à une des premières destinations
touristiques du monde comme je l'ai
souligné l'Île-de-France une capacité
développement économique à l'échelle
mondiale le monde a changé
ne correspond plus aux échelles
géographiques que nous avons connues la
perception de l'espace et la gestion de
déplacement ont été bouleversées par la
mondialisation le fait 21e siècle c'est
celui du phénomène de la métropolisation
les grandes capitales s'apprendent
désormais comme des villes monde ou des
villes régions c'est déjà le cas de New
York Tokyo et Londres notre région
Île-de-France n'a pas encorechevé ce
processus il faut donc accompagner cette
région pour qu'elle reste dans la
compétition mondiale
or ce Grand Paris Région Île-de-France
et une faiblesse forte c'est qu'elle ne
dispose pas d'une façade maritime
aujourd'hui 80% des marchandises
transitent par la mer ne pas prendre
cela en considération et ne pas se doter
de moyens de capter ce graphique
c'est finalement se priver au niveau
national de participer pleinement au
commerce international la plupart des
grandes villes du monde et des grandes
régions disposent de l'ouverture
maritime New York Shanghai bombé avec le
port de jawharal nerud Hong Kong
Singapour Tokyo Los Angeles c'est où
Londres pour qu'elle soit compétitive à
l'image des régions monde
l'Ile-de-France devrait avoir cette
façade maritime
les ports du Havre et de Rouen en
Haute-Normandie ont constitué d'or et
déjà avec les Ports de Paris un complexe
portuaire majeur en Europe baptisé aROPA
et qui a été reconnu meilleur peur
européen 2014
par électeur du journal cargo new Asia
leader de la presse professionnelle en
Asie en 95 la traiter un million de
conteneurs et envers 2 millions en 2012
Le Havre traité 2 millions de containers
et envers humiliant vous voyez bien que
malgré ses forêts accompli que les
bateaux ne s'arrêtent pas au port du Ham
ils vont au nord de l'Europe et une
partie de la France est alimentée par
les cantoneurs qui arrivent de Rotterdam
en verre ou en bourre en évitant de port
je termine les nouvelles régions que
vous souhaitez créer
auront des nouveaux présidents qui
doivent conforter leur rôle de stratège
économique quel sera quel sera la
stratégie du président de l'île de
France pour développer sa puissance
économique et de sa région
pour rester en phase avec les
mondialisation s'il ne contrôle pas tous
ses atouts notamment le contrôle de sa
façade maritime la question qui se pose
est de savoir si la façade maritime la
Haute-Normandie doit intégrer à
l'ensemble de la région Île-de-France
région Grand Paris comme l'avait demandé
d'ailleurs en 2010 les élus Laurent
fabuleuses sur Fnac et les dessinateurs
d'ici ou bien si dans la compétition
mandale la Grande Région Île-de-France
doit se contenter merci coopération avec
une région différente qui gère ce que
dalle maritime j'ai déposé l'allemand ce
sens merci le président de m'avoir
accordé quelques minutes de plus mais je
crois que c'est un débat c'est pas un
amendement d'appel c'est plus un
amendement de réflexion que je voulais
vous faire pour que vous remercie merci
chers collègues pour remettre fin un
soutenable suspens pour que vous
puissiez vous y préparer je veux vous
dire que nous suspendrons la séance à
17h45 et je précise par ailleurs qu'il
n'y a pas de temps additionnel à nos
interventions prévues dans
l'organisation de nos débats c'est 5
minutes pour chaque prise de parole la
parole est à André Richard
c'est le Président Monsieur les
ministres mes chers collègues notre pays
est en crise et doit se réformer nous en
avons je crois tous parfaitement
conscience dans cet enceinte nous
perdons durement en compétitivité nous
entreprises ne vont pas bien notre état
qu'on le veuille ou non est faible et la
structure politique ou administrative
est aujourd'hui perçue par nos
concitoyens mais également par nos
partenaires étrangers pour certains au
minimum comme un millefeuille peu
lisible pour d'autres comme un frein à
la croissance dans ce contexte sont
constituer la solution nous pensons sur
ces banques il y en a d'autres et on le
dit souvent une réforme des
collectivités à du sens
elle peut à défaut d'autres réformes
contribuer à améliorer les choses
mais cela a une condition sinequanone
une au moins
c'est qu'on ne perde pas de vue
l'objectif principal
permettez un alsacien qui a fait
campagne pour la collectivité
territoriale unique en Alsace dont on
connaît le résultat de le dire si l'on
veut porter une réforme territoriale
messieurs les ministres il faut avant
tout parler de compétences il faut
parler de levier pour l'action
économique l'innovation la recherche la
formation en un mot de levier pour
l'emploi il faut ensuite réconcilier nos
concitoyens dont au premier plan la
jeunesse avec leurs institutions dont
les collectivités territoriales bien sûr
il faut que nos concitoyens se les
approprient ces collectivités
territoriales et ses institutions
qu'elle sache à quoi elles correspondent
il faut éviter la dispersion des moyens
il faut éviter la fragmentation des
compétences il faut éviter la dilution
des responsabilités il faut enfin
réformer l'État tout autant que les
collectivités or à quoi sommes-nous
conviés aujourd'hui à nous prononcer sur
un texte relatif à la délimitation des
régions aux élections régionales et
départementales et modifiant le
calendrier électoral texte qui doit
ramener de 22 à 14 nombre des régions
métropolitaines et reportées à décembre
2015 des élections cantonales et
régionales qui étaient prévues en mars
prochain est-ce bien là
la réponse que nous devons apporter à la
situation dans laquelle une autre pays
nous avions pourtant là l'occasion d'un
débat de fonds qui aurait supposé qu'on
commence par les compétences les
éventuels nouveaux pouvoirs
réglementaires et en Alsace avec le
droit local on sait ce dont on parle et
nous aurions aussi souhaité commencer
par parler des moyens plutôt que
commencer par le découpage on aurait à
tout le moins au minimum actif et mes
articuler la discussion de la carte avec
celle des compétences des moyens et des
finances
la nécessité de boucler une première loi
retardant des élections régionales
annoncées par beaucoup comme perdu
d'avance par le Président de la
République et son gouvernement a conduit
à renvoyer à l'automne le débat de fond
qui aurait dû être préalable il s'en
suit donc un ensemble de
vrais fausses questions qui perturbe le
débat
tel les mariages de région les futurs
capitales le nombre des élus
après la valse hésitation sur la
disparition puis le retour des
départements Val saisitation sur la
clause de compétences générales qu'il
faut-il le rappeler a été rétabli
uniquement parce qu'elle avait été
supprimée par Nicolas Sarkozy et le
gouvernement de François Fillon avant
d'être à nouveau supprimé dans les
textes actuels après la valse hésitation
sur le mode de désignation des élus avec
cette tentation de refaire le conseil
territorial à l'envers avant de changer
d'avis pour ne finalement rien changer
franchement après tout ça nous n'avions
pas besoin de César rangements
négociation petit marchandage sur le
périmètre des nouvelles grandes régions
qui ont pris le pas sur les vrais
priorités qui auraient pu ou du conduire
au vrai logique territoriales et
faciliter les choix géographiques une
réforme territoriale cela doit se
construire dans le dialogue dans la
durée et de manière partagée bien sûr on
sait qu'il y aura toujours des
résistances explorer cela sera difficile
mais avec de la méthode on peut se
faciliter la tâche or là on en arrive
quand même à des niveaux d'improvisation
majeur qui justifie pleinement toutes
les réactions rencontrées lesquelles
viennent d'ailleurs en grande partie de
la majorité présidentielle monsieur le
ministre vous avez malheureusement pris
la réforme à l'envers en Alsace on dit
vous lui demandez d'acheter le chat dans
le sac vous avez malheureusement pris la
réforme à l'envers et c'est la raison
pour laquelle pour éviter que nous aussi
nous soyons entraînés dans des
discussions géographiques sans fin et
sans cadre au préalable il convient de
remettre les choses dans l'ordre en
supprimant l'AR ticle 1 ce sera bien
entendu le sens de mon vote
merci
la parole est à présent monsieur le
Premier ministre Jean-Pierre Raffarin
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres mes chers collègues cet
article me pose beaucoup de problèmes je
suis très perplexe parce que j'y trouve
de très bonnes choses mais j'ai trouvé
aussi un certain nombre de problèmes
d'abord dans ce qui est bon je crois
vraiment qu'il faut une réforme je crois
vraiment que les Girondins doit être les
plus réformateurs car la
décentralisation mourir Mora de
conservatisme si elle est pas capable de
se réformer et nous voyons bien que tout
le monde à faire des efforts y compris
financiers que tout le monde doit
participer à ses efforts et que s'il a
décentralisation et collectivités dans
leur ensemble ne sont pas dans ce
mouvement de réforme elle resteront
immobile et donc elles seront condamnées
il faut donc faire une réforme je n'ai
personnellement rien au contraire contre
l'idée de grande région je pense que les
grandes régions peuvent être à condition
qu'elles étaient des missions
stratégiques des lieux de programmation
des lieux de véritables puissances et je
pense que elles peuvent être vraiment
une un facteur de rénovation de notre
décentralisation en donnant à des
structures une véritable puissance et
enfin troisième satisfaction je note
vraiment avec bonheur que ni le
gouvernement ni le groupe socialiste ne
sont hostiles à l'idée d'une grande
région Aquitaine qui rassemblerait
la région Poitou-Charente avec
l'Aquitaine et le Limousin donc il y a
des choses positives et je trouve que
cet article qui présente tout cela a des
aspects qui pourraient convaincre mais
j'ai quand même trois problèmes graves
je vais pas revenir sur ces problèmes on
ne les a beaucoup évoqués la question de
la cohérence dans son ensemble la
cohérence entre grande région et
départements autant je peux accepter
l'idée de grande région à quelle
condition que la proximité soit défendue
par le département et donc là le
raisonnement de mon point de vue est
bancal et je pense qu'il y a aussi cette
ce problème de cohérence entre le
contenant et le contenu c'était la
question du périmètre et la question des
compétences 1 un problème de vision de
cohérence 2 une question fondamentale
sur la carte je pense que cette carte a
besoin d'une très forte légitimité je
pense que la manière de rendre tout ça
très fragile c'est donner le sentiment
que la carte serait un arrangement de
notable et qui de gens qui à un moment
ou un autre dans des hémices même très
nombreux pourrait décider de mêler
l'histoire la géographie et de manière
assez rapide de donner le sentiment
qu'on va faire une carte d'en haut à un
public d'en bas qui lui attend de
participer à ce débat monsieur Dantec
s'est exprimé ce matin sur ce sujet
j'étais pour la première fois assez
d'accord avec tout ce qu'il disait il
faut donner du temps pour que la
légitimité je vois aujourd'hui des
collectivités qui se prononcent je vois
aujourd'hui des sondages qui arrivent je
pense que tout ceci est nécessaire à
l'émergence Dieu de cartes très
franchement je l'ai déjà dit mais je le
redis moi je me sens tout à fait capable
de m'engager fortement pour dire que
l'avenir de Poitou-Charentes est plutôt
du côté de l'Aquitaine mais ça ça veut
dire que par rapport à la carte de
l'État
la région Centre qu'est-ce qu'on fait
alors sous prétexte que moi j'ai un
choix le deuxième choix alors il va se
balader et là je suis pas en situation
aujourd'hui de pouvoir déterminer si la
région Centre doit aller avec les Pays
de la Loire ou une autre solution et
donc je souhaite que sur ces sujets là
on donne plus de temps de d'études des
bas de démocratie locale pour qu'on
puisse donner de la force à une carte
qui serait une carte légitime et qui
serait pas contesté parce que si on fait
une carte pour l'histoire et c'est ce
que nous voulons faire il est clair que
cette carte devrait être acceptée et
vous savez bien qu'à toutes les
frontières la carte sera discutée il
faut il faut donner de la légitimité à
notre décision et si elle apparaît comme
un arrangement entre quelques
responsables nationaux ont privera cette
carte de la légitimité nécessaire alors
en terminant ce que je ne veux pas être
négatif monsieur le ministre messieurs
les ministres moi je suis prêt nous
sommes prêts ici à participer comme nous
l'avons fait avec Yves stratagé comme
nous l'avons fait avec Jean-Jacques avec
Michel Delbarre avec un certain nombre
d'autres vins moi je suis prêt à prendre
le pari avec vous que le Sénat vous sort
une carte à l'automne ou une proposition
qui aura été discutée qui aura été
débattue comme nous avons fait des
consensus sur ce sujet nous sommes
capables de faire un consensus sur une
carte avec une discussion mais qui sera
une discussion non brutale rapide qui
tiendra compte de ce qui sera dit et
vous aurez pour la deuxième lecture une
proposition sénatoriale qui serait une
proposition raisonnée mais en même temps
discuter voilà pourquoi je voudrais vous
dire que sur l'ensemble de cet article
je voterai le rejet mais je reste très
ouvert et j'apprécie un certain nombre
d'évolutions qui vont je me semble-t-il
dans une bonne direction
merci merci la parole est à René Paul
Savary oui merci monsieur le Président
pour aller dans le même sens que
j'apprière Raffarin je crois qu'à force
de discuter nous arrivons nous arrivons
à commencer à avoir le début des choses
et l'organisation éventuelle du
territoire ça nous permettra
d'argumenter que voulez-vous jusqu'à
présent on est complètement démuni par
rapport par rapport aux arguments à
donner sur la future configuration c'est
Monsieur les ministres c'était un
dimanche il y a quelques semaines
lorsque il y avait ce débat non pas ce
débat mais ces propositions qui qui
commençaient à
avancer au niveau le plus haut de l'État
et un dimanche une manifestation
mémorable la commémoration des 200 des
200 ans de la bataille de France 1814
sur les terres Montmirail dans la Marne
et dans l'Aisne à cheval sur les deux et
toutes les personnalités étaient là 1000
représentants qui reconstituaient la
bataille de France extraordinaire le
président de région était là les
téléphones sonnent on apprend par la
presse que la région Champagne-Ardenne
est associée à la Lorraine et l'Alsace
les bras nous tombent non pas due au
conflit mais due à l'annonce et en
conséquence avec le président de Région
aussitôt on a le même réflexe on avait
entendu des bruits on dit il y a quelque
chose qui va pas nous avions une
centralité nous étions chef-lieu de
région et on va se retrouver 17e région
sur les 22 et on va se retrouver dans
une grande région à un bout de région où
notre métropole dans le département de
la Marne c'est où c'est Paris nous
sommes à trois quarts d'heure de Paris à
100 km de Paris et demain on va
expliquer que notre pétropole régional
c'est Strasbourg ou Metz ou Nancy il y a
quelque chose qui va pas dans l'approche
et on manque d'arguments pour pouvoir le
justifier et puis deux jours après le
mardi soir je m'en souviens bien voilà
la Champagne-Ardenne on la prend à la
télévision associer à la Picard nos amis
Picards pourquoi pas laine et
limitrophes on a un pôle de
compétitivité sauf que quand on regarde
les distances ça commence un petit peu à
nous faire avancer dans une réflexion
assez particulière puisque la
Haute-Marne je vous le répète
= distance de la Provence que de la Baie
de Somme et quand on regarde les
Pays-Bas le taux de chômage la
population tout de suite au lieu de 17e
nous revoilà douzième sur 13 région
continentale on dit que quelque part ça
pas suffisamment avancé et c'est la
raison pour laquelle sans parents du
dossier avec le président de région avec
d'autres élus on se dit que peut-être
notre vision de cet aménagement dans le
sens des grandes régions c'est de se
tourner à la fois de la Picardie puisque
nous avions une académie commune avec
l'aide à un moment mais également avec
la Lorraine pour nos amis Laurons avec
qui nous avons un pôle de compétitivité
matérial des infrastructures un certain
nombre de choses des avancées qui nous
permettent de réfléchir c'est la raison
pour laquelle j'avais présenté un
amendement m Champagne-Ardenne Lorraine
qui conforte véritablement
décentralité certes je prêche pour ma
paroisse la complémentarité avec la
Lorraine et qui satisfait les alsaciens
qui visiblement ont un droit local une
identité tout à fait forte que je
respecte bien entendu avec un PIB quand
même à 28000 habitants une volonté de
fusion des départements avec la région
qui leur permet effectivement ensemble
de faire rayonner la capitale
européenne qui est Strasbourg la
métropole donc on peut comprendre la
position des Alsaciens on peut
comprendre la position des régions
ballottées vous nous avez amené un
certain nombre d'arguments et on peut
pour certains les partager encore
faut-il se mettre d'accord monsieur le
ministre Cazeneuve hier quand j'ai
vacciné l'assemblée avec mes histoires
d'emploi que je craignais perdre vous
avez dit oui à juste titre il y aura une
réorganisation des services de l'État
derrière
tout à l'heure monsieur valini monsieur
le ministre valini pardon vous nous avez
dit ne vous inquiétez pas on ne touche
pas la réorganisation territoriale
derrière rassurer vos fonctionnaires vos
fonctionnaires à vous de l'État qui nous
disent finalement on va aller à
Strasbourg ce sera peut-être Metz
différemment vous allez rester là
rassurer tous ces fonctionnaires est-ce
que il y aura derrière cette
réorganisation de l'État qui a des
conséquences primordiales pour l'avancée
de tout cela en conséquence car je ne
souhaite pas être trop long tant que
nous n'avons pas nous ne savons pas le
qui fait quoi quand tant que nous le
savons pas quelles sont les compétences
bien précises débattues au sein de ces
assemblées de ces futurs région nous ne
pouvons pas avoir les arguments pour
aller dans le sens de l'histoire donc je
crois que si chacun fait un pas se
comprend et fait en sorte que l'on
puisse avoir à la fois les compétences
les moyens et la carte
ce qui peut se produire lors d'une
deuxième lecture de la carte simultanée
de la première lecture de la deuxième
loi qui fait en sorte que nous ayons
plus de précision et nous ayons amendé
vos propositions on peut peut-être se
retrouver et il faut effectivement que
cette carte vienne d'une consultation
locale comme la foire bien exprimée
Jean-Pierre Raffarin de façon à ce
qu'elle aille de la base vers le pouvoir
central c'est comme ça que je conçois la
décentralisation
merci
la parole est à François gros Didier oui
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres collègues il y a deux écoles
il y a l'école
qui voudrait qu'on rapproche les
départements des régions et il y a
l'école
veut la création de Grande Région et de
maintien des départements là on est
quand même dans une discussion un peu
usque parce que même ceux qui dans cette
assemblée quel que soit les rangs
pourraient partager l'idée d'une grande
région en fait le font tous avec l'idée
de maintien des départements que vous
avez décidé de supprimer dans la
séquence suivante mais qui est qui est
annoncé la simplification la
clarification la rationalisation et
l'optimisation pour être plus efficace
en dépenses en moins plaid selon moi
plutôt pour le rapprochement département
région un stricte partage des
compétences la fin des doublons la
parfaite coordination qu'il ne peut
mieux être assuré que par un nez unique
bref pour le conseiller territorial de
la réforme Sarkozy Fillon seulement
voilà seulement voilà comme pour la
réforme territoriale comme pour la TVA
sociale comme pour les quotas et bien
vous avez décidé de commencer par
défaire ceux qui va être ce qui avait
été fait et ensuite
d'abord en ayant la nécessité de la
réforme puis devant la réalité de cette
nécessité encore plus impérieuse et
urgente qu'il y a quelques années vous
essayez de faire la même chose tout en
faisant croire que vous faites
différemment il est vrai qu'il que vous
tentez d'atteindre le même but tout en
faisant moins bien mais pas pareil et ce
dans la confusion souvent dans la
contradiction et donc forcément dans
l'incompréhension
c'est un non-sens que dessiner ces
grandes régions en annonçant la fin des
départements car il n'y aurait plus rien
entre l'intercommunalité et la grande
région et ce n'est pas viable vous nous
expliquez que les régions actuelles
n'ont pas la taille pour soutenir la
comparaison avec les autres régions
européennes et que la compétition
interrégionale en Europe imposent de
fusionner nos régions c'est une vision
superficielle et parisienne j'ai été dix
ans vice-président de ma région la
Lorraine sous l'autorité du président
Longuet j'ai eu en charge la formation
la reconversion la réindustrialisation
et je tire de mon expérience une toute
autre vérité le lendemain de Sars avec
moins d'habitants moins d'un million
d'habitants moins d'habitants que le
département voisin de la Lorraine et de
la Moselle et donc bien moins que la
région Lorraine
mais en concentrant sur un Land les
compétences et les budgets des
départements des régions et d'une partie
de l'État central selon dispose de
moyens d'action considérablement
supérieures et je ne vous parle pas de
notre autre voisin le Luxembourg même
pas un tiers de notre département mais
avec quel autre puissance une Lorraine
forte à côté à certains besoins de
coopérer avec l'Alsace et là
Champagne-Ardenne les deux mais nous
n'avons pas attendu ce gouvernement pour
organiser la grande région mais la
Lorraine a d'abord besoin de ses
départements pour exister à côté du
Luxembourg de la Sarre et de la Rhénanie
Palatina c'est l'importance des
prérogatives et la concentration des
moyens qui donne la force au levier de
l'action publique cette force se perdra
dans d'immenses régions sans identité
sans légitimité qui nourriront des
antagonistes internes ça commence déjà
avec le choix des capitales régionales
ils éloigneront le pouvoir territorial
du terrain il justifieront le maintien
et même le renforcement des départements
dont vous annoncez pourtant la
suppression la comparaison si parisienne
est si technocratique entre notre carte
régionale et celle de nos voisins ne
tient pas compte de notre histoire et
moins encore de notre géographie en la
matière comparaison n'est pas raison
note densité est plus faible la France
est sans habitants km², l'Allemagne
c'est 230 la Belgique 370 et les
Pays-Bas plus de 400 non comparaison
n'est pas raison le découpage est
déraisonnable dans son principe et les
plus encore dans les modalités décidez
en une après midi au château en quelques
heures des régions entières ont vu leur
destin basculer les hauts cris des gens
bien en cours ont été entendus Madame
Royal et Madame Aubry ont été
satisfaites Monsieur Le Drian aussi se
tombait en disgrâce comme Monsieur
Hérault ont prêchait dans le désert
Nantes restera coupé de la Bretagne La
Rochelle bourgétule seront dans la même
région le plateau de langues disposera
contrairement à Paris d'une façade
maritime avec la Baie de Somme la France
ne peut pas être redécoupée dans une
telle irrationalité au seul motif de
faire une réforme pour la réforme qui ne
soit pas la réforme antérieure voilà
pourquoi la raison nous commande de
rejeter cet article premier merci la
parole au Président mes arts
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre
ainsi que mon groupe tout à fait
dans le sens des propos du Premier
ministre Raffarin car je crois que
que c'est la raison effectivement que
c'est la raison qu'il y a ici une grande
majorité de ces natrices et de sénateurs
qui ont un objectif commun par rapport à
la réforme territoriale ce sont les
méthodes que vous avez utilisées qui
nous mettent dans cette situation au
lieu de lire le titre du monde de cet
après-midi disant que
UMP communiste et radico s'aborde la
réforme ce qui est une vision
boboïste parisienne qui est tout à fait
évidente Paris n'est pas la France mais
je dirais que Paris n'est plus la France
et que cette vision technocratique et
des médias parisiens ne correspond plus
du tout à ce qui se passe dans nos
territoires alors
monsieur le ministre vous êtes un homme
de parole
donc vous ne péchez pas par commission
vous ne le faites que par omission
et je dirais que il y a une distorsion
que je comprends entre le discours du
premier ministre hier en question
d'actualité et ce qu'il a dit sur France
3 et votre réponse d'hier soir
vous n'avez répondu précisément à aucune
de nos questions car je pense que vous
n'avez pas voulu nous tromper
ultérieurement et je vous en sais gré
en effet nous n'avons pas eu de réponse
sur la position réelle du gouvernement
sur l'évolution de la carte et vous en
avez une
sur les raisons qui ont poussé tant le
président de la République que le
premier ministre a changé totalement de
stratégie après le discours de tulle du
19 janvier
pas de réponse
précise sur
la possibilité
d'opter pour les départements
immédiatement on est d'accord où on
n'est pas d'accord mais il faut
l'exprimer clairement
pas de réponse sur une éventuelle
modification du système électoral parce
que je vous l'ai dit hier le système
électoral que vous étendez à de très
grandes régions aura des conséquences
très graves d'abord par l'élimination
des sensibilités politiques minoritaires
par l'entrée avec position de force de
l'extrême droite dans toutes les grandes
régions je ne pense pas que vous ayez
bien assumé les conséquences de telles
décisions et en tout cas je vous redis
aujourd'hui très clairement que nous ne
pouvons consentir à notre élimination de
cette manière là
pas de réponse sur la représentation des
départements affaibliographie et sur
leur élimination quasi totale des
conseils régionaux mais êtes-vous
d'accord sur mon amendement pour cinq
conseillers régionaux parce que
s'abriter derrière le Conseil
constitutionnel c'est un peu trop facile
et avoir un amendement du Gouvernement
garantissant un seul
élu de nos départements sur 150 et bien
c'est le mépris absolu définitif de nos
territoires pas de réponse sur le
maintien ou non
des conseils j'ai des conseils
départementaux parce qu'il y a un
amendement du groupe socialiste qui est
d'ailleurs utilisé dans la presse de cet
après-midi mais où c'est amendement est
simplement
un instrument pour préparer les
élections sénatoriales de septembre et
dans ce cas-là il faut le dire ou alors
ou alors non mais moi j'ai l'habitude de
dire les choses mon cher président non
c'est pas des invalidités parce que je
partage exactement l'objectif de cet
amendement mais de deux choses c'est pas
à vous que j'en fais grief
président Guillaume je souhaite
simplement parce que j'ai voté cet
amendement et je le soutiendrai
je demande simplement au gouvernement de
nous dire clairement s'il est d'accord
avec l'objectif de cette amendement qui
a été qualifiée par certains de vos
collègues hier président Guillaume
d'amendement d'appel et bien quand on
fait un amendement d'appel c'est pour
provoquer une réponse voilà quel est le
sens de mon intervention j'espère
qu'elle vous convient bon voilà donc
c'est oui ou c'est non mais qu'on nous
dise clairement oui ou non
et Monsieur le Ministre aussi autre
question qui qui justifieront oui ou non
allez vous dévitaliser les conseils
départementaux parce que si je reprends
les propos de Monsieur le Premier
Ministre hier c'est pas du tout évident
quelle réponse aussi à la question du
transfert des personnels des
départements ruraux vers les métropoles
régionales ce sont des questions
précises qui justifient des réponses
précises et je vous le dis une nouvelle
fois il y aura une deuxième lecture mon
groupe en partie nous sommes prêts à la
concertation comme nous l'avons fait sur
tant de textes depuis deux ans à la
condition qu'il y ait une réelle volonté
de concertation c'est le sens de mon
intervention merci la parole est à
Christian Bourquin
Président Monsieur les ministres
je m'inscrirai dans le droit fil de
toutes ces interventions que nous avons
c'est après midi la plus récente celle
du président Premier ministre Raffarin
et du Président
nous devons donner de la légitimité à
tout ce que nous faisons
au passage j'ouvreur parenthèse je la
ferme de communiquer sur Mathieu foot et
te dire qu'on arrête n'est pas la
meilleure des communications de la de la
de la notoriété du Sénat
qu'on aille voir le match de foot
peut-être mais de communiquer là dessus
n'est vraiment pas bon je referme la
parenthèse mais je crois mon institution
le Sénat c'est pour ça que j'y siège et
que j'y travaille monsieur le sénateur
je sais pas qui s'adresse vos remarques
mais je dois je veux préciser je n'ai
fait aucun communiqué sur l'événement
dont vous par jour vous mettez pas en
cause je vous mettais en cause d'autres
qui ont communiqué là-dessus et qui sont
majoritaires ici et qui je crois c'est
pas de bon goût je le dis clairement on
a d'autres messages à envoyer nous les
élus tous réunis
je voudrais revenir sur cette légitimité
qui est nécessaire ce matin monsieur le
ministre tout de suite d'expression et
cet après-midi
se sont faites jour très calmement
pour exprimer notre travail
aller jusqu'à la carte mais sans la
présenter parce que on sait bien que
c'est à l'automne que ça se fera le vrai
texte et la vraie carte et que vous avez
votre bras exécutif qui s'appelle
l'Assemblée nationale en direct ici nous
sommes la chambre de réflexion et cette
réflexion
ce matin et cet après-midi lever
quelques ambiguïtés
il y a des réponses qui sont pas données
d'une manière générale présent miserdy
et un travail qui a été fait
la prise de conscience que pour les
conseils généraux urbain et leur oral
c'est un autre débat au sens où on sait
pas délimiter l'urbain et le rural et il
faudra bien les limiter c'est un futur
travail énorme où s'arrête d'Urbain ou
commence leur rural quelle rural celui
où les vaches broutent ou celui où on a
des constructions voilà
premier mais on a travaillé là-dessus on
a bien avancé le deuxième élément on a
balayé je crois désormais
cette référence au poids de population à
la surface terrienne d'une région on en
a pu parler je pense être le dernier à
fermer le ban là-dessus et tant mieux
parce que c'est vraiment pas une
référence c'est vraiment pas une
référence et je note que personne
aujourd'hui maintenant alors que c'était
le cas jusqu'à présent on fait aucune
référence aux autres régions d'Europe
parce qu'on fait référence aux grosses
régions d'Europe mais il y a des petites
régions d'Europe et je vous les citerai
si vous voulez mais je perdrai le
montant qui fonctionne et partout en
Europe il y a pas que des grandes
régions
des petites régions pas en Espagne en
Italie en Allemagne et on parle notre
débat ne s'est porté que sur le gros le
gros il en faut et c'est une évidence et
il faut faire la réforme pour cela mais
il y a de la place je dirais pour ceux
qui sont pas gros et c'est la vie et
c'est notre vie
donc on a beaucoup avancé aussi sur le
personnel on l'a évoqué on a exigé que
finalement il y est cette concertation
de la part de l'État mais de la part des
collectivités pour les associer les
faire suivre et qui est passé
d'inquiétude énorme ceux des conseils
généraux et régionaux surtout se
tiennent en réserve mes gars si cela
nous éclate à la figure et c'est pas
très loin vous savez ça peut aller très
vite pour l'instant tout est calme mais
c'est comme un individu qui se réveille
il dormait mais tout d'un coup il est
réveillé mesdames messieurs je crois que
tout cela bien évolué ce matin on peut
pas dire comme je l'ai entendu dans la
presse et je le vois et je le lis et
c'est lamentable et je soutiens le
Président mes arts il est écrit des
choses pour la France qui ne sont pas le
relais de ce travail qui se fait ici
pourtant il est clair et je pense qu'il
est entendable puisqu'il y a
identité de vues je dirais
c'était mythique qui est très large qui
est très large du PC à l'UMP en passant
par notre groupe mais on s'appelle pas
PC UMP on s'appelle et centre on
s'appelle pas PC UMP centre RDSE on
s'appelle le sénateur qui faisons qui
sont réformateurs et qui voulons faire
avancer la chose la messieurs
pour ma région donc on dit que on mesure
pas le feu où il y a j'ai eu cher
ministre Bernard Cazeneuve l'occasion de
vous le dire la presse l'a dit hier il y
avait une partie pour le foot dans
l'intérêt collectif que j'ai parlé la
presse la d'hier le sondage l'a dit je
crois être le record de France où il y a
le feu et je vous le redis il y a le feu
en Languedoc-Roussillon
56% aujourd'hui des habitants me suivent
dans les propos où moi je suis le relais
des 56% d'habitants la poule qui a fait
l’œuf ou l’œuf qui fait la poule je vous
le dis je vous le redis il y a le feu et
sur les professionnels sur l'économie
sur tous ces gens qui font la richesse
si aujourd'hui j'ai 30000 nouvelles
entreprises chaque année qui s'installe
dans ma région record national c'est
bien qu'il s'y passe quelque chose ce
n'est pas le droit de ne pas
le préciser je dois le faire respecter
vous le faites
respecter je vous en remercie j'ai
terminé Ré en vous disant que il y a des
régions de taille européenne qui
méritent que le Languedoc-Roussillon
parce que je veux que la presse le note
à toute sa place en voulant rester AVC
56% seul vous l'avez voté en commission
j'espère que le gouvernement le fera
suivre à hauteur de la sembler nationale
pour que justement ceux qui sont de
taille moyenne existent aussi et il y a
comme dans la population une place pour
les moyens je vous en remercie merci la
parole est à Eric d'olivier
le ministre chers collègues juste
quelques remarques parce que beaucoup de
choses ont été dites mais je sens qu'on
avance en tout cas dans la réflexion de
manière importante et tout à l'heure
quand mon collègue reichhard est
intervenu il a parlé de la crise de
l'emploi de l'économie et je pense que
c'est là quelle est l'essentiel bien sûr
de notre préoccupation actuelle et je
vous rappelle qu'hier le FMI a réduit la
prévision de croissance de la France à
0,7 au lieu de 1% ce qui devrait quand
même nous interpeller alors est-ce que
le débat que l'on a et la carte et les
économies que l'on nous a annoncé vont
arriver maintenant pour améliorer la
situation je n'y crois pas et d'ailleurs
tout à l'heure on a entendu le ministre
valini qui nous a dit finalement en ce
qui concerne le personnel on a une
estimation qui ferait que ça va coûter
20 millions d'euros et j'ai entendu mes
collègues qui ont dit il m'a manqué à
zéro il manque au moins 1-0 dans
l'estimation que vous avez faite puisque
nous nous l'avons fait sur nos
départements et que déjà nous avons des
chiffres beaucoup plus importants si on
les ramène au niveau national donc si
vous avez des chiffres monsieur le
ministre donnait les nous puisque on a
déjà pas d'études d'impact mais si vous
avez déjà quelques éléments n'hésitez
pas à nous les donner pour essayer
d'avancer je dois vous dire également
qu'on a besoin d'investissement et que
ce qui se passe on a parlé tout à
l'heure de l'inquiétude des personnels
il y a aussi l'inquiétude des élus il y
a la quiétude des élus régionaux il y a
la non connaissance des contrats de
projets état région il y a les
départements qui s'interrogent sur les
investissements qu'ils vont faire et il
y a les communautés de communes qui
intéressent leurs investissements et on
a cru entendre dire qu'on allait avoir
des mauvaises surprises en ce qui
concerne le bâtiment et les travaux
publics en matière d'emploi très
prochainement et là on va participer
malheureusement à cette situation
particulièrement dramatique mais non on
est là on discute de la carte alors on
discutons de la carte et comme l'a dit
tout à l'heure le Premier ministre
Raffarin nous sommes globalement tous
pour sortir une carte on a besoin de
sortir une carte on est favorable à une
carte le seul problème c'est qu'on n'est
pas en capacité aujourd'hui de sortir
une carte alors
ons le le texte on prend l'article si
l'article 2 pardon dont on parle
effectivement bon ça a l'air de pas
grand chose vous regardez les colonnes
nouvelles régions anciennes régions moi
je regarde celles par exemple au hasard
du centre
je vois centre tirais Limousin
nouvelle région et ancienne région je
vois 100, limousins virgule poitou-
Charente donc pour j'allais dire le
citoyen classique bon finalement ça se
ressemble il y a des virgules à la place
des tirets mais en réalité c'est quand
même une modification profonde vous
allez dans l'article 6 Vous trouvez la
liste des départements nous étions si
départements on est très aujourd'hui et
sur 150
élus enfin oui élu je pense que c'est
les élus en fournissait rien 150 élus il
y en aura par exemple 6 pour la Creuse
dans une région qui fera 600 km d'un
point à un autre et puis si vous allez à
l'article 12 ben on vous dit qu'il y
aura plus de département donc finalement
dans nos départements au lieu d'avoir 50
élus qui sont les conseillers généraux
et régionaux on leur a 5 ou 6 élus qui
représenteront le territoire ce qui est
quand même nous interpelle alors si l'on
va un peu plus loin je me dis finalement
allez je vais faire une carte je suis
plein de bonnes volonté centre tiens je
me mets avec Pays de Loire alors je mets
un tirer Pays de Loire font ça marche ça
fonctionne moi je suis content seul
problème c'est qu'hier j'ai entendu les
représentants des Pays de Loire en tout
cas les trois derniers intervenants qui
nous ont dit non non nous on veut pas
être avec les avec le Centre nous on
veut être avec la Bretagne ah bon alors
comment va-t-on faire est-ce que vous
pensez très sérieusement qu'aujourd'hui
ou demain dans les 24 ou 48 heures qui
nous restent moins les deux heures de
match est-ce que vous pensez qu'on est
en capacité de se mettre d'accord sur le
dos des autres c'est à dire sur le dos
de ceux qui ne sont pas là un certain
nombre de collègues et d'ailleurs j'ai
écouté dans les couloirs ce que disait
les uns les autres tout à l'heure je
discutais avec mon excellente collègue
Jacqueline Gouraud sur le sujet elle m'a
dit mais finalement quand on regarde la
carte ce serait pas idiot de faire une
grande région Ouest en mettant le centre
avec poitouche avec le pays de Pays de
Loire plus la Bretagne pourquoi pas la
limite pourquoi pas réfléchir non non
mais pourquoi pas oui non mais c'est
encore plus grand mais à ce moment là
on raisonne dans des très grandes
régions on en revient à des sujets qui
étaient plus proches du rapport Raffarin
cratingé qu'on ne peut pas ne pas citer
à chacune de nos interventions et puis à
ce moment-là cela conforte la réalité
des départements qu'on peut regrouper
également les uns avec les autres alors
c'est impossible impossible monsieur le
Premier monsieur le ministre pardon
excusez-moi j'ai pris de l'avance
monsieur le ministre c'est impossible de
reconstituer un tableau voire des
tableaux aujourd'hui en changeant de
lignes et de colonnes les régions comme
ça on prend un shaker on remue c'est un
peu ce qui s'est passé un dimanche et
puis finalement on sort on sort des
listes donc moi je souhaiterais que vous
nous donniez du temps c'est pas
compliqué mettons tous d'accord je sais
que un de vos problèmes c'est le temps
et c'est pour ça que vous avez passé ce
texte le premier pour qu'on puisse voter
un an après la date légitime ou limite
mais qu'est-ce que ça peut faire on
n'est pas trois mois après c'est le
Ministre on n'est pas trois mois près
donc donnez-nous du temps et si vous
nous donnez du temps je peux vous dire
qu'on sera à peu près tous d'accord pour
vous ressortir une carte de qualité qui
répondra aux besoins des entreprises des
citoyens des élus et des fonctionnaires
de nos collectivités et puis en plus
vous serez tellement heureux d'être
arrivé à sortir un bon texte que ça
mérite quand même un peu de patience
merci encore
monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres mes chers collègues je
commencerai par relever un paradoxe et
une contre-vérité le paradoxe c'est que
nous sommes nombreux dans cet assemblée
a souhaité une réforme territoriale la
preuve en est des travaux ont été
conduits sous d'autres maturités qui
aboutissait à une conclusion il fallait
réformer l'organisation administrative
de la France mais nous sommes confrontés
à cette difficulté qui est largement due
au choix que le gouvernement a fait de
vouloir élargir le périmètre des régions
je le dis avec beaucoup de force ici dès
lors que vous effaciez progressivement
les départements et les conseils
généraux en particulier il fallait se
tenir dans des limites qui
correspondaient à ce que Condorcet
exprimée en 1788 lui qui fixait le
périmètre des circonscriptions
administratives en fonction du temps que
l'on mettait pour aller du lieu central
aux extrémités des districts de l'époque
si vous aviez eu la sagesse simplement
de vous en tenir au régions qui existent
encore aujourd'hui
quitte à en élargir le périmètre pour
certaines d'entre elles et de ce point
de vue là je représente
l'Orne qui est en Basse-Normandie je ne
souhaite qu'une chaume monsieur le
ministre et vous le savez nous sommes
nombreux en tout cas dans ce cas là que
la Normandie soit réunifiée peut-être
d'autres ajustements
vous avez fait un autre choix qui je
crois plombe un peu votre réforme la
contre-vérité c'est celle qui est
exprimée par certains organes de presse
vraiment je le dis avec
beaucoup de solennité on ne peut pas
accuser qui que ce soit ici d'avoir
voulu retarder les débats d'avoir
utilisé des procédures
que vous nous avez enseigné mes chers
collègues lorsque vous étiez dans
l'opposition
des procédures pour retarder l'issue des
débats je note d'ailleurs je note
d'ailleurs que nos débats que nos débats
se déroulent dans le cadre temporel qui
avait été prévu par la Conférence des
Présidents il y a qu'un jour il n'y a
donc pas de retard puis regrette
également que des membres de cette Haute
Assemblée à l'extérieur de cette
hémicycle et plus relayer
l'idée que certains voulaient absolument
retardé voir saborder la réforme
j'en viens maintenant au fond
pour ce qui concerne
les régions il y a du temps à prendre je
crois que ce temps est utile monsieur le
ministre monsieur les ministres au
gouvernement et il est nécessaire à la
représentation nationale pourquoi est-il
utile pour le gouvernement
imaginons un seul instant que nous
votions le projet de loi qui nous est
présenté et que dans 15 jours
conformément au calendrier fixé par
l'Assemblée nationale celle-ci adopte le
texte cela voudrait dire qu'une loi
serait votée rapidement d'ici à la fin
du mois de juillet
elle est exposée à l'examen du Conseil
constitutionnel mais le Conseil
constitutionnel censuré évidemment cette
loi puisque le second train qui
dépend du premier n'aurait même pas été
présenté devant le Parlement à savoir
que le retard qui est mis pour les
élections locales départementales et
régionales ne se justifient que dès lors
qu'il y a une refonte des régions à
travers le transfert des compétences
nécessaires d'autre part pour la
représentation nationale j'étais frappé
au fond il y a deux faits nouveaux qui
sont apparus au cours de ces débats
lesquels sont utiles plus qu'utilisent
sont féconds
et il est vrai que
nous n'avons pas avancé dans l'examen
même du texte en sens qu'il n'y a pas eu
un amendement si il y a eu un amendement
de voter avant l'article premier mais
c'est la réflexion qui a progressé et
qui nous rassemble sur un certain nombre
de points
mais
rapidement nous allons nous rendre
compte que le temps que nous prenons
aura été utile et l'autre fait nouveau
monsieur le ministre c'est la main
tendue par Jean-Pierre Raffarin
j'ai été frappé par les propos qu'il a
tenu hier à la tribune qu'il a réitéré
tout à l'heure dans le débat il vous a
fait des propositions
il est sincère et nous nous retrouvons
derrière lui nous pouvons ensemble
aboutir à une carte qui soit conforme
aux souhait du plus grand nombre
messieurs les ministres ne refusait pas
cette main tendue merci la parole est à
Philippe basse
merci monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues sur cette carte il y a un
certain nombre de points d'accord et
beaucoup de points de désaccord le
ministre fait preuve d'ouverture
d'esprit et nous demande d'être
coopératif pour réduire les désaccords
et nous sommes nous aussi dans une
disposition coopérative et tout à fait
prêt à les réduire mais nous différen
fondamentalement sur la méthode vous
voulez demander au législateur de
procéder immédiatement par voie
d'autorité l'autorité de la loi
et nous répondons que ce n'est pas une
bonne méthode législative
de posséder par voie d'autorité sans
avoir préalablement concerté
vous pensez au fond que si on ne procède
pas à la hussarde sur ce sujet on y
arrivera jamais nous vous disons que si
l'on découpe les régions d'une manière
brutale et sans concertation préalable
et bien nous n'aurons pas le sentiment
d'adhésion qu'il faut pour que ces
régions fonctionnent convenablement avec
une cohésion et une ambition qui
permette aux politiques régionales de se
développer il faut pour de bonnes
régions en quelque sorte une affection
sociétatrice on n'aura pas cette
affection sociétatrice en procédant par
voie d'autorité alors bien sûr
il y a un moment où il faut trancher
mais je crois que
il y a des précédents et on l'a dit dans
la discussion générale qui montre que le
fait de d'assumer nos devoirs ici de
voir de législateur de voir du
gouvernement de prendre les décisions
qui lui appartiennent de voir des
préfets de prendre aussi leur décision
bien il y a des précédents par exemple
la coopération intercommunale dans le
cadre de la coopération intercommunale
il y a d'abord invitation des
collectivités à se regrouper discussions
entre elles l'élaboration d'une carte
départementale et décision du préfet le
préfet avalise les propositions qui lui
sont faites dans un certain nombre de
cas et quand il n'y a pas d'accord il
prend ses responsabilités et décide nous
vous demandons de faire la même chose
pour les régions de faire en sorte que
on est donné sa chance au dialogue avant
de procéder par voie d'autorité
législatives et nous avons largement le
temps de le faire car au fond comme je
le rappelais matin et aussi hier
le
la taille des régions doit dépendre des
missions qui leur sont confiées grande
région
souple flexible avec une mission de
projet économique et pour les grandes
infrastructures mais petites régions si
elles doivent avoir de gros bataillons
de cantonniers ou d'agents des collèges
parce que là ce sont des services
publics locaux qu'on rend mieux dans la
proximité avec moins de frais de
structure donc prenons le temps de
discuter des missions pendant ce temps
qui est déjà assez distendu compte tenu
du calendrier gouvernemental ouvrons une
concertation faisons-le d'ailleurs comme
vous entendez le faire dès l'article 2
pour la détermination des chefs-lieux
des nouvelles régions
mais ne procédons pas immédiatement par
des mesures brutales qui s'imposent à
tous y compris en cas de désaccord
cherchons d'abord de grâce à réduire ses
désaccords pour qu'on ne soit pas dans
la situation ou pendant des décennies on
pourra dire dans les régions nous nous
voulons pas être ensemble et certaines
parties de ces régions diront et nous
sommes la dernière roue du carrosse
personne ne s'occupe de nous et ce
mauvais c'est mauvaise fondation vont
avoir des conséquences extrêmement
graves dans la durée et puis si vous
aviez eu je dirais le chic de vous
soumettre à un dialogue préalable
combien plus fort auriez-vous été le
jour venu pour nous proposer de trancher
nous les législateurs et combien
aurions-nous été gêné si nous étions mal
intentionnés de résister à vos
propositions
alors je crois que il est maintenant
tout à fait établi que cette méthode de
gouvernement n'est pas la nôtre de même
que les solutions que vous proposez ne
sont pas les nôtres
merci c'est Christian Favier qui a la
parole
le Président Monsieur les ministres mes
chers collègues mon intervention sur cet
article 1 vaudra aussi pour la défense
de notre abonnement 105 qui porte sur la
suppression de l'article 1 cet article
premier donc fixant la nouvelle carte
régionale c'est donc bien effectivement
le cœur de la réforme qui nous est
proposée or si l'exposé des motifs et
peu loquace en matière d'objectifs et de
critères des regroupements
d'origine proposées l'étude d'impact
explicite mieux ses choix sans en
mesurer pour autant les conséquences
ainsi il y est écrit qu'il s'agit non
seulement d'adapter la carte régionale
aux réalités géographique sans plus de
précision mais aussi à l'Europe des
Régions est-il écrit voilà donc
effectivement l'objectif premier il nous
a demandé d'adapter notre pays donc à
cette perspective d'une Europe des
régions une Europe effectivement qui
rêve vers une Europe fédérale et
libérale deuxième objectif affiché alors
dans cette étude d'impact c'est celui du
redressement de l'économie et des
comptes publics sans que les
conséquences des fusions de région en
ces domaines ne soient réellement
étudiés elles ne sont qu'affirmées mais
non démontré et au contraire je crois
que tous les orateurs ici sur les bancs
de cette assemblée on fait la
démonstration que ces grandes régions
vont d'abord effectivement au contraire
entraînaient plutôt des surcoûts que des
économies notre rapporteur quant à lui
considère qu'avec ces nouvelles régions
l'objectif essentiel poursuivi par le
gouvernement serait la recherche d'une
puissance renforcée de nos régions dans
la européenne et mondiale et que dans ce
cadre la diminution du nombre de régions
serait considérée donc comme un facteur
d'efficacité sans lui non plus dépasser
le stade de l'affirmation sans la
moindre tentative de justification de
telles allégations et il serait
évidemment intéressant que nous
puissions débattre sur cette notion
puissance que l'on entend de plus en
plus à propos des régions en quoi de
grandes régions seraient-elle forcément
plus forte ou plus juste par exemple la
fusion de deux régions pauvres on le
sait bien ne fera jamais une région
riche et nous devrions alors nous
interroger sur les raisons qui nous font
en permanence nous comparer au Lander
allemand et à leur force en oubliant en
permanence de mentionner que cette
puissance était droitement liée
effectivement à leur pouvoir et au moyen
de dire d'une Constitution fédérale
faut-il rappeler que l'Allemagne n'est
pas une République une et indivisible et
que l'unité allemande est récente au
regard de notre état nation et que les
discriminations territoriales de toutes
sortes sont aussi le lot commun en
Allemagne alors oui quelle puissance
devrait atteindre nos régions et cette
puissance au service de quels objectifs
la développer rien malheureusement n'est
dit en la matière certes on discerte
management on parle d'efficacité mais
pourtant vers quoi pour répondre à
quelles attentes à quel besoin à quelle
réduction réelle des inégalités sociales
et territoriales en quoi par exemple le
transfert des routes ou des collèges aux
régions serait-il les va-t-il les rendre
plus performantes le risque c'est bien
au contraire et ça a été souligné de les
transformer en monstre technocratique
moins efficace et en tout cas moins
réactive y compris que les départements
les dernières élections en municipales
que européennes ont montré vous le savez
de fortes attentes citoyennes en termes
de participation et d'écoute ce texte
est-il une première réponse alors qu'au
nom de la puissance et d'efficacité ce
sont des structures plus éloignées
encore des citoyens avec moins d'élus
que l'on s'apprête à mettre en œuvre
aussi pour toutes ces raisons et pour
bien d'autres et notamment il faut bien
le dire l'absence quasi totale de
concertation pour préparer cette carte
nous vous proposerons donc de supprimer
cet article ce qui nous permettra
effectivement d'avoir au moins une
première lecture sur les compétences
avant de conclure en deuxième lecture
sur les périmètres les futurs régions
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Louis Pinton
monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres
deux mots pour constater que
à ce niveau de la discussion nous sommes
quand même un petit peu en difficulté
nous sommes en difficulté parce que
le traitement du sujet qui nous
intéresse de mon point de vue a été mal
abordé et pas assez approfondie
en fin de compte chacune et chacun de
nos concitoyens même des élus
ressentent un trouble extrêmement
important dans l'action publique locale
le gouvernement précédent c'était
interrogé longuement sur
les remèdes qu'il fallait apporter à ce
trouble
il avait fait une proposition c'était
celle du conseiller territorial qui de
mon point de vue était un début
d'approche du règlement de la situation
mais pas assez abouti et trop compliqué
en fin de compte
ce qui a manqué à la réflexion
c'est d'identifier
clairement
là où est le cœur du problème
peut-être qu'on l'a tous ressenti plus
ou moins inconsciemment mais on n'a pas
exprimé clairement là où était le cœur
du problème et de mon point de vue le
cœur du problème se situe dans la
relation département région
et tant que on ne réglera pas la
question de la relation département
région et que on fera des propositions
qui sont des propositions de traitement
du trouble mais de traitement
parcellaire on risque de faire beaucoup
plus de dégâts que d'apporter des
solutions et je veux dire que dans le
traitement qui nous est proposé
aujourd'hui
les territoires ruraux vont souffrir
énormément
et la République
qui est une et indivisible dans les
qualités ont été évoquées précédemment
ne peut pas ne peut pas mettre en place
des mesures qui sont dévastatrices pour
80% de son territoire ceci est
inadmissible et
arrivé à cette situation parce que vous
voulez forcer la marche
vous conduira à avoir une très lourde
responsabilité
dans la dévastation des territoires
ruraux alors je crois qu'il faut prendre
son temps qu'il faut régler le problème
de la relation département région pour
apporter la puissance et la proximité et
apporter ce que des territoires ruraux
sont en droit d'attendre d'attendre
d'une République qui a une histoire
extrêmement longue et qui plonge ses
racines même au-delà de ça en deçà de sa
naissance je pense qu'il faut prendre le
temps parce que on va faire énormément
de mal à notre équilibre national je
remercie merci la parole à Philippe
d'Allier
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres mes chers collègues au point
où nous en sommes rendus de ce très
intéressant débat il y a fort à parier
que l'article 1er de ce texte va
connaître un sort funeste et ainsi vidé
de sa substantifiquement le texte que
vous nous présentez
je lis déjà les articles de presse et
j'entends déjà certains de nos collègues
à l'Assemblée nationale
philippendait le Sénat pour cela nous
traitait de Sénat conservateur même mes
chers collègues je crois que ce que nous
allons faire c'est certainement le
meilleur service que nous pouvons rendre
au gouvernement que de lui donner du
temps et je vais vous rappeler un
souvenir qui remonte à une année
exactement c'était le texte sur la loi
métropole
concernant le Grand Paris le
gouvernement était venu devant le Sénat
avec une proposition critiquée sur tous
les bancs une proposition absolument
ubuesque une couche de plus dans le
mille-feuille une métropole qui aurait
compris 10 millions d'habitants sur les
12 millions de la région on y comprenait
rien personne ne voulait être ce texte
et le Sénat avait rendu une page blanche
nous avions été très critiqué à l'époque
mais qu'est-ce qu'il s'est passé ensuite
et bien oui mon cher collègue café oui
un mois mais il y a une seconde lecture
et c'était en décembre et c'est
exactement là que je veux venir en
rendant une page blanche le Sénat a
permis une réflexion supplémentaire et
partie de l'Assemblée nationale le
gouvernement est revenu ici avec un
texte radicalement différent qui crée
effectivement une véritable métropole et
nous avons trouvé ici une majorité
au-delà des clivages politiques
souvenez-vous avec Jean-Pierre Raffarin
avec Jean-Jacques Yeste avec d'autres
nous avons amendé ce texte et au bout du
compte nous l'avons adopté ça n'était
pas écrit d'avance même si ce texte sur
les métropoles du Grand Paris n'étaient
pas parfait à mes yeux en tous les cas
nous avions considéré que c'était une
avancée dans la bonne direction la le
sujet est encore plus important tout le
monde ici et surtout les bancs et même
au groupe socialiste nous le savons bien
porte la même appréciation sur ce texte
nous aurions dû discuter des compétences
et des moyens en même temps que nous
discutions effectivement du relais
coupage alors Monsieur les ministres où
est l'urgence où est l'urgence pourquoi
ne pas prendre l'été septembre et
octobre pour retravailler ce texte et
essayer de faire en sorte effectivement
que nous trouvions ici une bonne
solution non pas pour les deux ou trois
ans qui viennent mais pour les 50 années
qui viennent parce qu'une réforme de
cette importance bien évidemment
quelle durera pendant un demi-siècle à
tout le moins alors messieurs les
ministres le Sénat va à mon avis
supprimer effectivement cet article
premier je pense qu'il fait bien cela
vous donne du temps utilisez ce temps et
revenez devant la Haute Assemblée avec
un texte au cours dans lequel nous
pourrons effectivement discuter des
compétences des moyens et des périmètres
parce que si effectivement ces trois
éléments là ne sont pas sur la table en
même temps il n'y a pas beaucoup de
chance effectivement au bout du compte
que le résultat que nous produirons soit
un bon résultat merci Roland Dantec à la
parole
oui en écoutant notre dernier collègue
je me disais ce que l'article 1 ne
survivra peut-être pas à la discussion
et au vote à venir qu'il est un peu
dommage qu'on n'est pas voté ce que nous
avons proposé je le dis en toute
immunitie comme
des marches dans un des amendements qui
sera balayé c'est l'article 1 et
supprimer qui était de dire
effectivement et là je rejoins ceux qui
sont exprimés avant moi avec lesquels je
ne suis pas toujours en accord politique
sur le fait qu'un peu donner un peu de
temps au temps et nécessaire à ce stade
je ne le dis pas de manière théorique
quand je regarde ce qui est en train de
se passer entre Bretagne et Pays de la
Loire je vois que finalement ce qui
était impossible il y a quelques
semaines avec par exemple le sondage qui
est sorti hier qui dit que les opinions
publiques des deux régions sont
défavorables au statu quo qu'il y a des
choses qui peuvent qui peuvent bouger
elles ne peuvent bouger que si les élus
se rencontrent plus et un des paradoxes
de la situation Bretagne et Pays de la
Loire c'est que il y a beaucoup de
coopération entre les deux régions mais
des élus qui finalement se parlent assez
peu c'est la réalité des choses et donc
ce temps peut être mis à profit pour y
arriver et donc mon intervention n'est
pas du tout là-dessus dilatoire et
certains services l'initiative que j'ai
pris avec d'autres parlementaires avec
Bretagne l'appel Bretagne rassemblée
pour trouver un équilibre entre fusion
Bretagne et Pays de la Loire et dans ce
cadre une expérimentation quelque chose
d'un peu novateur pour garantir aussi et
ça a été beaucoup dit depuis hier à la
dimension historique et culturelle de la
Bretagne à 5 départements donc il y a de
la place effectivement pour du débat à
condition de se laisser quelques
semaines pas de se laisser 10 ans mais
de se laisser quelques semaines donc le
fait effectivement de travailler la
carte à l'automne en deuxième lecture et
en lien comme l'a dit notre collègue
Favier avec la lecture des compétences
de dans la loi le branchu est assez
cohérent
mais mais j'ai aussi beaucoup entendu
parler de contrats de main tendue alors
je voudrais je voudrais vérifier deux
trois choses à ce niveau là parce que je
voudrais pas que tout cela soit malgré
tout un peu dilatoire et que certains
souhaiteraient surtout que rien ne bouge
qu'on garde des petites régions qu'on
garde des départements et qu'on part et
qu'on passe par pertes et profils et les
schémas prescriptifs qui sont dans la
loi le brancher ce qui n'est absolument
pas mon cas est-ce que nous sommes
d'accord sur la règle du jeu est-ce que
nous sommes vraiment d'accord sur la
règle du jeu clairement si l'article a
un tombe ça nous donne la responsabilité
de travailler à une boîte à outils qui
sera ramenée vers l'Assemblée nationale
et là on peut évidemment s'appuyer sur
l'excellent travail du rapporteur Michel
Dolbar qui a proposé des amendements
assez consensuels sur la boîte à outils
on ne peut pas dire d'un côté on attend
pour la carte et de l'autre côté ne pas
travailler sérieusement sur la boîte à
outils qui va éclairer dans les régions
le processus pour permettre des régions
plus grandes parce qu'il s'agit quand
même de permettre des plus grande il y a
une cohérence entre les deux lois il y a
une cohérence avec ces grands schémas de
développement économique dans le
renforcement du rôle de développement
économique des régions d'avoir des
régions plus grandes des régions à deux
départements des régions qui ne
correspondent pas à la trappe à la trame
urbaine ça ne colle pas et donc il faut
bien des régions plus grandes je ne sais
pas si tout le monde est d'accord sur le
fait qu'il faut arriver là et à ce
niveau-là la proposition que nous
faisions était justement de dire nous
laissons du temps au temps mais aussi
très clairement il sera de la
responsabilité de l'État et du
gouvernement pour ceux qui n'arriveront
pas à se mettre d'accord de mettre quand
même sur la table à un moment des
fusions parce que si dans trois mois
c'est juste pour constater les accords
et la volonté de ne pas bouger alors je
serai le premier à soutenir le
gouvernement pour dire et bien puisque
vous n'y êtes pas arrivé voilà comment
nous allons fusionner et redécouper la
France donc si nous sommes bien d'accord
sur ce contrat global qui veut dire
qu'on expédi bien une boîte à à outils
vers l'Assemblée nationale et qu'on
travaille bien dans le sens des fusions
de région je laisse la question des
départements qui n'est prévue dans
aucune des deux lois pour l'instant dans
un débat à suivre alors je pense
qu'effectivement nous pouvons sortir de
ce débat avec quelque chose qui ne
serait pas simplement un séma un sénat
pardon chambre des collectivités
territoriales incapables de se prononcer
sur ce texte merci Gérard roche la
parole
il y a un petit flou dans mon esprit
parce que je sais pas si on est dans le
discussion de la suppression de
l'article si on n'est pas encore mais on
fait Christian Favier tout à l'heure
indiqué qu'il avait présenté et c'est
là-dessus que je vais donc prendre la
parole et revenir sur ce que je disais
ce matin et prendre l'image j'aime bien
parler par image c'est que on nous
propose une course à montagne avec des
sommets qui sont nébuleux on sait pas on
voit pas bien clair sur ce que vont
devenir les communes personne parle des
communes on ne parle pas non plus de des
recettes il y a quand même des silences
qui sont sourds ça et puis le manque de
préparation nous dit on part pas de 50
ans en basket tout ça est c'est donc un
problème de conscience pour chacun
d'entre nous et avec qui allons nous
partir
je vais parler de la déesse puisque je
suis au bureau de la DF nous avons fait
plusieurs réunion de la DF et mes
collègues et amis socialistes président
conseil généraux DJ est là il tient de
la place mais les autres qui étaient
très très remontés en particulier
méfions-nous dès la première loi il y a
l'article 12 dans l'article 12 est
inscrit implicitement la disparition de
dépassement 2020 il faut pas se laisser
faire et tous ses collègues et ben ils
sont pas là aujourd'hui
alors partir sans qu'il soit là aussi ça
nous pose un problème et ça ça ne fait
que accroître un peu notre inquiétude
mais j'ai dit ce matin que c'était un
cas de conscience pour chacun d'entre
nous nous sommes élus par des grands
électeurs qui sur le territoire sont
très attentifs à tout ce qui se passe
actuellement aujourd'hui ils sont tous
très inquiets ils partagent tous notre
angoisse il partage tous nos inquiétudes
et nos interrogations alors en ce qui
concerne la suppression de l'article
cela veut dire qu'on va laisser partir
une copie blanche à l'Assemblée
nationale et beaucoup d'entre nous au
groupe udi pensent que c'est de notre
devoir décrire cette page avant qu'elle
aille là-bas parce que nous nos
électeurs nos grands électeurs ce qui
nous ont fait confiance comprendront
comprendrez pas que on laisse partir
cette caserne directement à l'Assemblée
nationale et qu'elle accès à nous de
l'écrire en premier puisque nous sommes
la collectivité qui s'occupe de
l'organisation territoriale et des
territoires aussi dans sa majorité mais
pas dans sa totalité alité mais dans sa
majorité notre groupe est plutôt
favorable à ce que nous continuons la
discussion et donc ne pas favorable à la
suppression de l'article 1
si la parole est à Marie-Noël Linde oui
monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues à cette étape du débat je
voudrais vous dire les grands doutes qui
m'habitent sur cette réforme pour ma
part je considère que l'engagement du
président de la République l'engagement
54 quand il était candidat fixait le CAM
des réformes des collectivités locales
qui correspondaient aux besoins de notre
pays aujourd'hui
il ne parlait absolument pas de la
modification des différents échelons
moins encore de la disparition du
département et d'ailleurs il a trouvé un
plaidoyer que je pourrais vous donner
tout à fait convaincant lors des Assises
de notre Sénat sur les collectivités
locales le 5 octobre 2012
il parlait de l'autonomie renforcée et
surtout de la clarification des
compétences il parlait d'ailleurs du
maintien et du renforcement des
dotations au collectivités locales
pour ma part je pense que c'est la
feuille de route qui correspond aux
besoins du pays une première étape a été
votée une deuxième celle de la
clarification des compétences s'impose
il arrive que nous soyons amenés à
évoluer et à proposer des réformes qui
n'étaient pas dans les programmes
gouvernementaux
mais dans les programmes initial ça
arrive mais en général mieux vaut faire
des réformes qu'on a prévu qu'on a prévu
et qui
correspondent à un mandat et en
particulier je rappelle la réforme
fiscale car j'ai très peu entendu parler
des outils fiscaux et financiers qui
seront donnés aux collectivités locales
pour répondre à leurs besoins
et deuxièmement si on fait des nouvelles
réformes mieux vaut qu'elle rassemble
d'abord la majorité auxquelles de
laquelle tire sa légitimité les le
président et d'autre part qu'elle
rassemble les Français or visiblement si
j'en crois les nombreuses de libérations
des collectivités locales telles n'est
pas le cas pour celle-ci j'ai bien
entendu les arguments sur la taille des
régions
pour ma part je n'ai jamais été sensible
à cet argument je pourrais admettre que
deux régions bénévolement souhaitent
fusionner se rapprocher qu'on favorise
se rapprochement et cette fusion mais
théoriser le fait que pour être
compétitif il faut être gros aux motif
qu'il faudrait ressembler aux Européens
permettez-moi de vous dire que tel n'est
pas le cas
la deuxième région la plus dynamique
d'Allemagne et la région de Hambourg qui
compte un million 800 000 habitants
donc nous avons toute une série
d'origine qui peuvent être petites et
performantes
nous avons aussi de grossesions qui
accumulent les énormes problèmes dans
certains territoires de l'Union
européenne la deuxième argumentaire
c'est ça permettrait d'économiser de
l'argent ou d'avoir une activité plus
ciblée pour soutenir le redressement
industriel du pays
d'abord la fusion de région coûte cher
pendant toute une période avant de faire
des économies somme toute assez limitées
quand on regarde dans la durée il y a
une étude qui a été faite très en détail
et vous la connaissez madame monsieur le
ministre c'est une étude correspondant à
la fusion entre la haute et la Basse
Normandie cette étude commandée par les
collectivités territoriales a mis en
évidence un certain nombre de
conséquences qui méritent d'être
réfléchie pendant 8 à 9 ans
l'augmentation elle coûte globalement 15
millions la fusion pendant 8 à 9 ans ça
va augmenter les dépenses et pas les
baisser c'est seulement au bout de la
neuvième ou dixième année que ces
dépenses pourraient baisser de 0,3 0,5%
des frais de fonctionnement
dans le même moment l'étude montre que
si le siège était Rouen de la capitale
régionale
4000 emplois seraient supprimés de quand
pour progressivement aller à Rouen or il
vous échappera pas que 4000 emplois
supplémentaires dans une ville moyenne
comme Caen qui n'est pas les plus
démunis et la plus si je puis dire
retarder de nous de nous villes va
inévitablement avoir un impact
d'aménagement du territoire qu'on ne
peut pas balayer d'un revers de main
donc pour ma part je suis plus que
dubitatif sur l'économie financière
faite sur ses fusions enfin si j'ai des
doutes sur les fusions de région j'ai
une certitude sur l'intérêt de maintenir
des départements en France si on peut
avoir une réflexion sur l'opportunité
des départements métropoles comme
historiquement par exemple pour Paris il
y a eu ou à Lyon fusion entre les deux
pour ma part je crois que le département
reste un échelon
utile pertinent pour les politiques de
solidarité pour les politiques de
péréquation entre les zones urbaines et
rurales car il n'y a pas d'un côté
l'urbain total et le rural total nous
sommes toujours dans une symbiose et
c'est ça la richesse de la diversité des
territoires français donc pour ma part
j'en termine je pense que cette réforme
n'est pas la priorité et puisqu'on nous
parle des compétences j'observe que
c'est moins souvent l'embroglio des
codes et politiques publiques locales
qui est en cause que le désengagement de
l'État et j'en prends pour preuve le
logement à mesure que l'État a baissé
dans la pierre la Broglio des
collectivités locales sur le logement à
paralysé notre production et là
effectivement il y a une méditation à
voir sur les compétences merci la parole
est au président Didier Guillaume
je suis le président Monsieur et les
ministres mes chers collègues ce débat
est très intéressant d'ailleurs depuis
le début de notre discussion générale ce
débat est très intéressant parfois nous
parlons du texte parfois nous parlons du
contexte parfois nous pendant un texte
qui n'existe pas par pas nous parlons de
transfert d'éventuels compétences dont
nous ne savons pas ce qu'elle pourrait
être absolument et en fait
j'ai relu ou plutôt pour être très juste
j'ai fait étudier ce matin toutes les
interventions qui ont été faites en
discussion générale
et je me suis aperçu que dans les deux
groupes numériquement les plus
importants de notre assemblée force est
de constater que tout le monde n'est pas
sur la même position si on regarde au
fond du sujet et du de la discussion
générale et si on comparait ce qui s'est
passé ce matin et cet après-midi dans
ces prises de parole sur article c'était
à nouveau une discussion générale
le président Raffarin a fait des
propositions attendues de main je vais
essayer de lui répondre mais en même
temps on parle de tout à la fois
et si on décortique un peu ce qui s'est
dit certains sont pour des grandes
régions d'autre part certains sont pour
supprimer les départements d'autre part
on pourrait le faire en zone rurale mais
pas forcément en zone urbaine certains
sont départementalistes d'autres sont
régionalistes et à partir de là il faut
quand même arriver à trouver une
solution puisque le gouvernement nous
sommes dans la 5e République et que le
gouvernement nous propose un texte qui
est sûrement un texte qui mérite d'être
amélioré mais qui est un texte de base
qui est important c'est quand même la
première fois depuis 20 ou 30 ans depuis
la décentralisation Mitterrand mon roi
de fer qu'il y a un texte qui va
chambouler l'administration territoriale
parce que mes chers
merci de me traiter d'amnésie m'a fait
jusqu'à preuve du contraire jusqu'à
preuve du contraire le conseiller
territorial fusionnait les régions et
les départements
le corps bah il a pas eu lieu
vous me laissez parler vous me laissez
parler monsieur Grosdidier est éructait
pas laissez-moi parler s'il vous plaît
je dis simplement que la loi de 2010 que
vous avez voté que nous avons bien fait
de supprimer c'est dans la loi dire
l'inverse c'est
erroné fusionner les régions et les
départements pour faire un camp chez
territorial qui qui est j'ai à la fois
aux régions au département si vous dites
l'inverse monsieur gruddidier vous
mentez laissez-moi parler donc sur le
sujet donc sur le sujet il y a il y a
moyen de discuter et Monsieur Raffin
tout à l'heure attendu une main
en disant mais pourquoi
n'arriverions-nous pas ensemble à
regarder pour redécouper des grandes
régions très bien hier beaucoup d'entre
vous ne sont pas allés dans cette
direction et j'apprécie la main tendue
de du Premier ministre à Farin sur ce
sujet parce que depuis des années nous
sommes à peu près tous d'accord pour
dire qu'il faut des grandes régions
ensuite le sujet ce sont les
départements et là à droite comme à
gauche nous ne sommes pas favorables à
la suppression pure et simple des
conseils généraux pour ma part en zone
urbaine ça ne me pose pas de problème
nous pouvons être en désaccord mais ça
ne peut ça ne peut pas de problème et si
vous aviez été là hier après-midi
monsieur Grosdidier aux questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement vous auriez
entendu le Premier ministre lui-même là
au banc pour dire oui mais ça vous
arrive tellement souvent au banc pour
dire pour dire que les zones rurales
seraient préservées donc à partir donc à
partir de là ma proposition est la
suivante
on peut repousser la discussion toujours
mais si votre position c'est de dire il
faut absolument que les élections se
tiennent en 2015 alors je n'y suis pas
favorable pas pour du tripatouage des
trucs électoralistes ça n'a aucun sens
tout ça parce qu'on sait pas ce qui se
passera en 2015 et peut-être pas non
plus en 2016 sauf que aller à des
élections en 2015 et durant ce présente
à la région en se présente au
département mais il y aura une loi qui
va changer tout ça on ne sait pas de
quoi il s'agira pour ma part ça n'a
aucun sens donc il faut bien que cette
loi soit votée la tradition c'est un an
avant l'élection pour arriver à ce que
lors de l'élection en sache à quoi s'en
tenir et honnêtement monsieur Dallier
tout à l'heure par rapport à ce qu'il
disait vous croyez qu'il y a beaucoup de
sénateurs qui vont travailler en août et
en septembre pour travailler
souhaite-loi pas alors qu'il y a des
élections sénatoriales je ne le crois
pas je ne le crois pas donc nous avons
du temps nous en parlons depuis des
années moi je proposerai bien la limite
puisque nous avons le temps encore
demain et dimanche que nous suspendions
la séance maintenant
que la Commission non c'est pas pour
cette raison que la commission spéciale
se réunissent et que la Commission
spéciale sur la foi des débats qu'il y a
eu hier et cet après-midi sur la main
tendue du Premier ministre Raffarin nous
regardions si la possibilité de se
mettre d'accord sur un socle des grandes
régions des départements maintenus en
zone rurale le droit d'option et si nous
arrivions à cela la discussion de ces
deux ou trois jours aurait été utile ça
peut être une proposition elle risque
d'être refusée mais moi je pense
vraiment que nous ne pouvons pas j'ai
fermé fini monsieur le Président nous ne
pouvons pas aller aux prochaines
élections régionales et cantonales avec
ne pas savoir ce que serait la loi merci
merci en attendant je suis je suis saisi
de trois amendements
madame Debré merci de vous signaler s'il
vous plaît
ça va être très très rapide c'est juste
pour répondre à président Guillaume vous
dites que la commission spéciale peut se
réunir cet après-midi demain samedi
dimanche pour établir une carte mais
c'est pas du tout ce que le Président le
premier ministre Raffarin a suggéré il a
demandé d'écouter il l'a dit lui-même
les élus je dirais de la base d'en bas
pour faire remonter en haut et vous vous
proposez quoi que les élus d'en haut
finalement se réunissent dans une petite
salle
vous avez dit vous avez dit je
ne vous ai pas interrompu j'ai dit que
j'allais être rapide
le Président le premier ministre
Raffarin vous a tendu une main en disant
qu'on allait écouter les élus de la base
qu'on allait écouter les sondages qu'on
allait écouter les revendications des
élus de terrain pour essayer d'établir
une carte et vous vous répondez à cette
main tendue en disant on va prendre la
commission spéciale on va rester deux
jours enfermés dans une petite pièce
pour établir une carte donc c'est pas
tout à fait ce que vous proposez le
Premier ministre Raffarin c'est tout ce
que je voulais dire merci la parole est
à présent monsieur le ministre
bien beaucoup d'interventions une fois
de plus ont eu lieu sur tous les bancs
pour entrer dans la discussion de cet
article premier d'abord il faut toujours
voir le côté positif des débats et la
dynamique qu'il porte je constate que ce
matin encore nous étions tous dans une
discussion ou répondante au
parlementaire de l'opposition nous
étions obligés de justifier de la
pertinence de la réforme voilà qu'après
le déjeuner on nous explique qu'elle est
possible et qu'il faut prendre du temps
pour la faire des bâtons encore trois
heures et nous le ferons ensemble
des choses progressent c'est à dire que
vous ne contestez plus aujourd'hui qu'il
faille cette réforme vous le contestez
plus à l'heure où nous sommes là cet
après-midi qu'il faille rapprocher des
régions pour faire en sorte que nous
ayons un tissu de collectivités
territoriale plus fort et plus puissant
c'est donc que vous rejoignez finalement
ce que vous dites en permanence c'est
que ce pays a besoin de réformes mais
lorsque la majorité les propose ce ne
sont jamais les bonnes ce qui vous
permet d'ailleurs de continuer à dire
qu'il n'y en a pas assez c'est l'un des
discours qui a sa cohérence vous
regrettez que les réformes ne soient pas
faites quant au gouvernement les propose
et propose de les faire vite parce que
vous dites systématiquement que les
réformes doivent être faites dans
l'urgence parce qu'on a trop attendu ce
ne sont jamais les bonnes et bien nous
nous avons décidé d'agir nous avons
décidé d'agir de prendre des décisions
de proposer à la délibération du
Parlement des lois qui transforme leur
profondément notre pays parce que nous
considérons que notre pays a besoin
d'être réformé d'être transformé et nous
ne voulons pas le faire de façon aut
nous ne voulons pas le faire de façon
unilatérale nous voulons le faire avec
vous c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
indiqué à plusieurs reprises au cours
des dernières heures que nous étions
absolument prêt à prendre des
amendements et maintenant de tous les
banques dès lors qu'il permettait de
faire en sorte que le texte qui sortira
de Sénat et de l'Assemblée nationale
soit garanti d'être meilleur le deuxième
point qui rejoint d'ailleurs la première
préoccupation que je viens d'exprimer
sur l'urgence des réformes c'est sur la
pertinence de la carte beaucoup d'entre
vous se sont exprimés pour dire mais
nous nous sommes d'accord pour l'affaire
la réforme nous sommes même d'accord
pour approcher des régions mais nous
considérons que la carte qui nous est
proposée n'est pas la bonne et de
conclure que pour il dit qu'il y ait une
carte il faut que la discussion sur
l'article premier et qui permettrait
d'amender la carte proposée par le
gouvernement n'est pas lieu que cet
article soit supprimé que nous nous
revoyons plus tard quand les esprits
auront mûri et cheminées
mais nous nous proposons précisément que
si la carte n'est pas bonne et nous
l'acceptons volontiers parce que nous
considérons qu'il était difficile d'en
proposer une de parfaite et bien ayant
la discussion pour l'améliorer
d'ailleurs vous savez très bien pour
beaucoup d'entre vous qui vous êtes
essayés cet exercice qu'il est très
difficile de proposer sur les sujets les
plus compliqués des réformes les plus
pertinent d'un coup parce que il arrive
sur les questions de la géographie de la
politique qu'il y ait autant d'avis
qu'il y a qu'il y a d'élus dans les
territoires je voudrais d'ailleurs vous
faire une confidence j'ai reçu beaucoup
d'élus au cours des dernières semaines
sur cette question là j'ai vu toutes les
configurations j'ai vu des élus qui sont
venus me dire que les cartes proposées
par le gouvernement correspondait
parfaitement à ce qu'il souhaitait et
qu'il ses élus d'ailleurs c'était
exprimés pour proposer des regroupements
de leur région avant même que le
gouvernement ne proposait de légiférer
d'autres sont venus de région bien
connues me dire nous nous considérons
que ce que propose le gouvernement est
très bien
mais les parlementaires de notre région
ne sont pas favorables à ce que les
présidents de région proposent donc
comme je suis la même sensibilité que
les parlementaires qui s'opposent à la
réforme que je préconise je ne vais pas
trop le dire fort je ne vais pas trop le
nom ils étaient de droite je vais pas le
dire trop fort mais je tiens à vous
assurer monsieur le ministre que je suis
absolument en accord avec la réforme que
vous proposez je vous demande surtout de
ne pas céder au parlementaire de
l'opposition qui vous propose de faire
autrement j'ai des noms je ne les
donnerai pas pour ne pas les
compromettre parce que je me suis engagé
à ne pas le faire mais monsieur le
sénateur Lenoir à mes bons amis en qui
j'ai confiance je donnerai les noms je
les donnerai vous je vous donnerez les
noms j'ai des noms il y a d'autres
parlementaires qui sont venus me dire
d'autre parlementaires et président de
région qui sont venus me dire que cette
carte n'était pas celle qu'il fallait
faire et qu'ils en proposeraient une
autre dont tact qui la propose cela ne
pose pas de problème nous sommes dans
une démarche je le redis
où nous vous confirmons qu'il était
difficile de proposer une carte qui
fasse uneanimité parce que cette carte
n'existe pas vous proposez qu'il y en
est une autre et bien allons-y amendons
travaillons réfléchissons ensemble pour
que cette carte correspondent le plus
possible au bon compromis dont nous
avons besoin
le troisième sujet dont je voudrais vous
dire un mot c'est sur les différentes
questions qui ont été évoquées notamment
par Jacques mesard Jacques mesardin nous
sommes prêts à parler à condition qu'on
est des réponses précises mais je vais
redonner ces réponses précises et je
souhaite qu'elle soit comme toujours
consignée au compte-rendu pour qu'on ne
puisse pas dire qu'à un moment ou un
autre je me suis refusé à les apporter
et je vais aller dans le détail d'abord
les principes qui président à la réforme
c'est faire en sorte qu'au terme de
notre débat et de du processus
d'amendement il n'y ait pas plus de
régions qu'il n'y en a au moment où le
texte entre parce que si nous devions
sortir de ce débat avec autant ou plus
de régions qu'il y en avait au moment où
nous sommes rentrés l'objectif n'aurait
pas été atteint mais à partir du moment
où nous sommes dans la même équation
concernant le nombre de régions nous
sommes prêts à accepter bien des
amendements venant du Sénat de tous ces
bancs pour faire en sorte que la carte
soit meilleure première réponse deuxième
réponse le président Jacques MESORE dit
nous voulons que le gouvernement nous
dit ce qu'il pense du droit d'option
mais là aussi je réponds précisément
nous n'avons pas souhaité que l'on fasse
à la fois de la transformation des
quatre régionales et du droit d'option
pour les départements pourquoi parce que
nous aurions ajouté de la difficulté
technique à la difficulté technique et
si nous voulons que ce débat puisse
aboutir à un moment donné à une carte et
un accord il n'est pas nécessaire de
rendre une question complexe plus
compliquée encore est-ce que ça veut
dire que jamais la question du droit
d'option des départements ne se posera
non vous avez présenté les amendements
en ce sens et j'ai indiqué devant la
commission des lois que nous étions tout
à fait prêts dès lors qu'il y avait une
carte parce que pour qu'il y ait un
droit d'option il faut qu'il y ait une
carte un droit d'option sans carte ça
n'a pas de sens donc dès lors qu'il y a
une carte il y a des amendements sur le
droit d'option rien ne s'oppose à ce que
nous discutions de ce sujet ensuite la
question qui est posée par Jacques
mesard elle est également très précise à
l'appel une réponse qui le soit tout
autant nous considérons que le nombre de
livres par région peut poser des
problèmes pour ceux qui concerne le
plafond du nombre d'élus et pour ce qui
concerne le nombre minimum d'élus par
département notamment pour les
départements les plus ruraux des régions
les plus grandes j'ai également répondu
à cette question précisément à
l'occasion du débat d'hier en disant que
des événements avaient été préparés
notamment par votre rapporteur
concernant le plafond sur lesquels le
gouvernement était prêt à engager avec
vous le débat il y a donc pas de
fermeture je le redis à Jacques Mesa sur
ce point et concernant le nombre le
nombre de conseillers régionaux des
départements les plus ruraux des grandes
régions il n'était pas garanti ces
départements d'avoir avec le mode de
scrutin actuel dans le cadre des régions
actuelles un représentant l'article 7
garantit qu'ils en auront un et si des
amendements qui sont
assurer d'être constitutionnel et par
conséquent qui peuvent être recevables
sont présentés j'ai dit notre dispositif
notre disponibilité à les examiner
absolument autre question précise posée
par Jacques mesard l'avenir des
départements mais ne bloquons pas un
débat sur la carte régionale en raison
de ce qui se passerait sur les
départements alors même que la question
de l'avenir des départements n'est pas
dans le texte que l'on examine non ce
n'est pas dans le texte que l'on examine
je suis désolé si vous trouvez un
article dans le texte que l'on examine
qui parle de la question de la
suppression interne des conseils
départementaux présentez le moi sur le
champ et je vous dirai mes excuses
d'avoir il n'y a pas cette question
pourquoi il n'y a pas cette question je
vais vous dire pourquoi il n'y a pas
cette question et je regrette que l'on
fasse peur avec ce sujet
pour la raison suivante c'est que notre
effort ce sont des intercommunalités
fortes ce sont des régions puissantes ce
sont des administrations des concentrés
de l'État qui s'organisent et je redirai
un mot sur les raisons pour lesquelles
nous le faisons et comment nous le
faisons et puis c'est à terme
à l'horizon 2020 c'est à dire nous avons
encore 6 ans pour en parler vous voulez
le temps du débat mais nous avons 6 ans
pour parler de cette question la
suppression des conseils départementaux
si l'architecture territoriale que nous
mettons en place à travers l'ensemble de
ces réformes permet de le faire sans
préjudice pour la solidarité pour la
proximité c'est à dire sans préjudice de
toutes les questions que vous évoquez
pendant ces débats vous voulez du temps
on vous en donne vous voulez de la
proximité et vous voulez la garantie
qu'il n'y aura pas de décrochage des
territoires
nous proposons que la question la plus
sensible qui doit faire l'objet du débat
le plus long soit traité dans 6 ans de
telle sorte à ce que ce débat est lieu
que faut-il faire de plus pour
satisfaire des élus qui se posent des
questions légitimes en étant sincère et
franc quant à la méthode quant aux
objectifs quant à la démarche j'avoue
que je ne sais pas quel est le chemin ou
quelle est l'argument supplémentaire
témoignant de notre bonne foi qui
permettrait de vous convaincre voilà
pour ce qui concerne les départements
ensuite il y a une question qui est
lancinante depuis ce matin elle est
double
il faut y répondre précisément ce sont
les économies et les fonctionnaires
alors je veux m'attarder sur les
économies et les fonctionnaires parce
que on ne fait pas de réformes en
faisant peur les fonctionnaires on en a
supprimé beaucoup au cours des dernières
années à ce moment-là ça n'a ému
personne quand on était dans la révision
générale des politiques publiques mais
moi j'assume parfaitement ce que je vais
vous dire mais non et Monsieur
grosdiguier vous inquiétez pas vous
allez partir d'ici avec des garanties
des assurances j'assume parfaitement ce
que je dis devant vous et je vais être
très précis vous avez supprimé pendant
des années un nombre de fonctionnaires
considérables sans chaos aucun moment
vous ne vous soyez émus des conséquences
que cela pouvait avoir sur les services
publics sur la proximité sur
l'administration des territoires qui
bien entendu suppose pour être efficace
qu'on lui maintienne des moyens ça ne
vous a ému à aucun moment à aucun moment
vous ne vous êtes posé la question de
savoir si la suppression d'un
fonctionnaire sur deux dans les
territoires avaient des conséquences sur
la proximité sur la solidarité et je le
dis très amicalement au sénateur de
l'igier sur le moral des fonctionnaires
ça vous a pas préoccupé du tout et voilà
maintenant que vous êtes dans une
approche absolument qualinothérapie des
fonctionnaires dont vous avez diminué
drastiquement les effectifs subitement
sans doute parce que vous trouvez dans
l'opposition et que d'autres qui sont
dans la majorité qui ne menacent pas les
fonctionnaires se propose au contraire
de renforcer l'administration des
concentrés d'État sur les territoires
alors vous parlez des fonctionnaires des
collectivités locales mais je vais vous
répondre sur les fonctionnaires des
collectivités locales demain si nous
fusionnons des régions entre elles ça
c'est pour les fonctionnaires de les
collectivités régionales vous dites mais
il va y avoir des transferts massifs de
capital à une autre même madame linman a
dit il y aura moins 4000 employés à Caen
bon mais soyons un peu sérieux ces
sujets-là doivent se traiter quand même
en méthode et en rigueur si demain il y
a des fusions de régions et que nous
décidons de rassembler les fonctions RH
parce que ça fait des économies nous
nous voulons faire 50 milliards c'est
pas assez à vos yeux vous en voulez sans
mais vous quand on propose de faire des
rationalisations vous considérez que ces
rationalisations ne sont pas les bonnes
que ça va faire des dépenses en moi vous
voulez faire 100 milliards d'économie
d'économie mais sans faire de dépenses
en moins il faut nous expliquer comment
on fait donc oui nous nous voulons faire
des économies passant comme vous mes 50
et comment est-ce que nous les faisons
et bien quand nous rassemblons parce que
des régions fusionnent des fonctions RH
des fonctions financières des fonctions
de support je le dis à Monsieur Savary
aussi parce qu'il a évoqué la question à
plusieurs reprises lorsque nous décidons
de transférer les collèges et les routes
aux régions qu'est-ce que nous faisons
nous permettons aux régions d'avoir une
politique d'achat groupé qui permet de
faire des économies massives je tiens à
vous signaler mais je le dis au présent
mes arts aussi que la politique d'achat
que nous avons mise en oeuvre au sein de
l'État depuis deux ans a permis des
économiser 2 milliards 5 parce que quand
vous regroupez les achats vous avez un
effet d'économie massif et bien entendu
que tous les départs en retraite ne sont
peut-être pas remplacer dans les
collectivités locales dès lors que nous
procéderons à ces regroupements parce
qu'il y aura des rationalisations mais
ça ne veut pas dire qu'il y aura des
licenciements ça veut pas dire qu'il y a
lieu de faire peur aux fonctionnaires
qui sont aujourd'hui en poste ça veut
dire simplement que par l'effet de la
mutualisation et de la rationalisation
nous serons capables de faire des
économies de fonctionnement ce qui est
nécessaire pour le redressement de nos
comptes et ce qui est nécessaire aussi
si nous voulons dégager des marges de
manœuvre qui permettent aux
collectivités locales d'investir vous
avez dit pendant des années qu'il
fallait dans les collectivités locales
dépensez moins pour investir plus et
quand nous prenons les mesures
d'organisation qui permettent de
dépenser moins pour investir plus y
compris dans le service public voilà que
vous n'êtes plus d'accord mais la vie
politique française s'épuise de ces de
ces positionnements ou lorsque l'on est
dans la majorité on propose une chose et
lorsque l'opposition le fait parce qu'on
l'a pas fait soi-même ça devient une
mauvaise idée tout cela ne correspond
pas à ceux dont les Français ont besoin
à ce que les Français attendent donc oui
nous allons procéder à des organisations
non cela ne niera pas au fonctionnaires
oui cela fera des économies de
fonctionnement et oui cela permettra
d'investir dans les services publics
parce que c'est une nécessité pour le
pays parce que c'est une nécessité pour
le redressement de nos comptes parce que
c'est une nécessité pour la croissance
il n'y aura pas de croissance en France
s'il n'y a pas de maîtrise de nos
dépenses de fonctionnement pour faire en
sorte qu'il y ait des marges de manœuvre
pour l'investissement voilà ce que nous
voulons faire pour ce qui concerne les
fonctionnaires quant au fonctionnaires
de l'État pour ceux qui concerne les
capitales des régions de demain il n'est
pas obligé de mettre tous les services
publics dans la capitale si vous êtes
préoccupé comme nous le sommes
d'aménagement du territoire il peut très
bien les voir des collectivités locales
dans lesquelles il y a des assemblées
des libératives et des préfectures de
région et des services publics qui se
répartis sur l'ensemble du territoire
avec une unité de commandement tout
simplement pour apporter la
démonstration qu'il n'y a pas de
contradiction entre la modernité entre
la rationalisation et entre la proximité
ce que l'on peut faire très facilement
comme démonstration à condition d'être
dans l'imagination dans la créativité
dans la modernisation de l'État et des
d'éviter locale et non pas dans la
citation des peurs non pas dans la
pusillanimité non pas dans cette idée
que comme hier était parfait demain sera
pire qu'hier dès lors qu'on fait en
sorte que demain soit différent d'hier
je ne crois pas du tout que l'on puisse
raisonner comme ça dans un pays qui est
affronté à autant de défis et qui doit
faire tant de démonstration de sa
capacité à se réformer enfin je veux
conclure sur un point qui est essentiel
beaucoup de sénateurs ont évoqué cette
question ils ont raison c'est la
question des territoires ruraux vous
avez peur légitimement qu'il y ait un
décrochage des territoires ruraux vous
avez peur légitimement pourquoi non pas
parce que se décrochage est devant nous
mais parce que ça fait des années qu'il
se produit des années il y a depuis des
années une relégation des territoires
héros depuis des années vous avez des
campagnes qui se désertifient vous avez
des agriculteurs qui vivent dans un
habitat diffus vous avez des services
publics qui ont quitté les territoires
héros depuis très longtemps et qui ont
été pénalisés lourdement par les effets
de la révision générale des politiques
publiques qui ont vu les services de
l'État s'appauvrir se rétrécir
considérablement et bien si non ça ne va
pas s'accentuer ça ne va pas s'accentuer
si on a une politique qui permet de
lutter contre ça et quelle doit être
cette politique cette politique est une
politique qui doit consister à travers
l'administration des concentrés de
l'État qui ne va pas reprendre les
pouvoirs des collectivités locales il
s'agit pas de recentraliser mais qui va
prendre un certain nombre de compétences
qui sont centralisées pour les mettre
sur les territoires de faire en sorte
qui est un déploiement et un
développement de l'administration des
concentré sur les territoires notamment
sur les territoires héros c'est une
nécessité si on veut éviter le
décrochage c'est aussi une nécessité de
bien réfléchir et ce sera l'objet de la
loi porter par André vallignier et
marie-glise le branchu sur la
répartition des compétences pour que
nous ayons des collectivités locales qui
déploient les compétences dans la
proximité notamment dans les territoires
ruraux donc nous ne pouvons pas réformer
un pays avec des peurs qu'on agite avec
des craintes qu'on brandit comme des
spectres on ne peut pas réformer un pays
si l'on est en perm dans l'idée que rien
ne peut changer parce qu'à chaque fois
que l'on change quelque chose ce sont
des services qui reculent ou des
citoyens qui s'éloignent du centre de
décision politique donc moi je vous
propose que l'on soit dans la sincérité
dans l'engagement dans l'authenticité
d'un dialogue que l'on décide de
transformer nos territoires d'engager
cette réforme territoriale et qu'on le
fasse non pas dans la suspicion dans le
procès d'intention mais en prenant le
gouvernement aux mots et en faisant en
sorte que le gouvernement soit jugé non
pas sur les intentions qu'on lui prête
mais sur les actes qu'ils portent et
qu'il pose et sur les paroles qu'il
prononce devant la représentation
nationale avec respect et détermination
merci je suis donc saisi de trois
amendements identiques de suppression
faisant l'objet d'une discussion commune
l'amendement 37 rectifié terre de
Monsieur Husson lament demande 53
rectifié terre de Monsieur Doliger la
maindemment 105 de Monsieur Favier
amendement
37 rectifiés terre de Monsieur Husson
est présenté par Monsieur Savary oui
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre effectivement maintenant on
arrive à l'heure de vérité il faut
passer à l'acte à travers cet article 1
qui les proposé de de supprimer je crois
que Jean-Pierre Raffarin avait été très
clair une main avait été tendue vous
l'avez refusé à travers vos propos
si monsieur le rapporteur et je le dis
de façon très sympathique et non pas
très agressive vous l'avez refusé parce
que suite au discours de Monsieur le
Ministre rien n'a changé rien n'a changé
nous prétendons que cette carte soit la
conséquence de la répartition des
conséquences des conséquences des moyens
et des compétences d'évoluent à chaque
niveau territorial aucune avancée dans
votre réponse sur le plan régional
aucune avancée sur le plan départemental
de garantie d'un département équilibré
sur deux jambes amortisseurs sociales
aménageurs du territoire aucune avancée
en ce qui concerne la taille des
intercommunalités
en ce qui concerne les économies
monsieur le ministre
Cissé des économies au niveau des achats
groupés mais recentralisons tous ces
dispositifs et la taille permettra de
faire encore des économies est-ce que
dans le cas des transports scolaires le
fait de faire des appels
d'offres encore plus importantes ne va
pas tuer les entreprises locales qui
nous dépannent aujourd'hui est-ce que
dans le cadre des déneigement de route
le fait de faire des appels d'offres
plus importants va régler les problèmes
au niveau des régions où l'enneigement
n'est pas simultané un endroit à l'autre
contenu de la taille des régions et où
ce sont là aussi les entreprises locales
ou les agriculteurs dans les zones
rurales qui déneigent nos routes non je
crois que c'est une économie minime
l'achat groupé qui peut toujours se
faire dans une entente de collectivités
qu'elle soit départementale régionale ou
intercommunal ils peuvent ensemble faire
des achats groupés dès l'instant où il y
a une volonté non monsieur le ministre
vous n'avez pas répondu à l'appel que
nous avons fait et nous restons bien sûr
sur la même théorie à savoir que le
Sénat est dans son rôle le Sénat d'un
Soro la s'opposé à cet article car les
choses ne sont pas mis dans le bon sens
et nous prétendons qu'il faut définir
les compétences les moyens la fiscalité
attribuée à chaque niveau de
collectivité la pérennité de ces
collectivités pour pouvoir prendre les
décisions c'est à la deuxième lecture
que l'on pourra prendre des décisions en
même temps que la première lecture sur
la deuxième partie de votre loi en ce
qui concerne les la dévolution des
compétences et peut-être les moyens qui
seront à louer à cette future
organisation donc nous présentons cet
amendement de suppression
pour la présente pour présenter
l'amendement 53 rectifié terre monsieur
Doligé
c'est un amendement qui bien sûr à la
même finalité je savais pas que mes
collègues seraient si nombreux à le
déposer également simplement je voudrais
dire à monsieur le ministre qu'il a
raison il a raison puisque sur une des
réponses qu'il a faite tout à l'heure à
Monsieur mesard d'ailleurs j'avais posé
exactement les 5 mêmes questions hier
lors de mon interrogation
lors de mon propos
introductif vous avez raison il est pas
marqué que les départements vont
disparaître en 2020 donc j'ai relu
effectivement le texte comme quoi
parfois on est un peu impressionné par
des interventions qui peuvent venir de
personnalités importantes au niveau
national puisque dans l'article 12 il
est marqué le mandat des conseillers
départementaux élus en décembre 2015
prendra fin en mars 2020 donc
effectivement il est pas marqué que les
départements disparaitront le problème
c'est que le Président de la République
a quand même dit mais peut-être que ce
qu'il dit
n'a peut-être pas une importance ma pour
ceux qui l'entendent en tout cas du
gouvernement mais pour nous qui sommes
des citoyens ordinaires s'apaisent quand
le président de la République dit
quelque chose il nous a dit les
départements ont vécu et on va faire en
sorte qu'ils disparaissent à l'horizon
2020 donc si on additionne ces deux
remarques qui ont été faites par le
Président de la République voir par le
Premier ministre et qu'on l'ajoute au
petit 3 de l'article 12 c'est quand même
la fin des départements tels que c'est
écrit ou alors on ne sait pas lire et ce
qui est dit n'a aucune importance donc
vous avez raison monsieur le ministre ça
n'est pas écrit dans le texte mais
subliminalement ça nous a quand même été
dit un certain nombre de fois par le
Président de la République et je ne
voudrais pas vous vexer mais je crois
plus en la parole du président de la
République quand celle de ces ministres
première chose deuxièmement sur les
économies je voudrais vous dire Monsieur
le Ministre qu'effectivement on peut
faire des économies et
je voudrais dire mais faut-il encore
qu'on nous aide et c'est peut-être là
que la loi serait intéressante je
voudrais dire que nous sommes trois
départements le 28 le 41 et le 45 je
vous laisse rechercher à quoi
correspondent ces chiffres qui se sont
regroupés sur qui se sont regroupés
depuis plus d'un an sur 20 thèmes dont
les achats et on a créé une centrale
d'achat qui s'appelle Aprolis qui est
ouverte à tout le monde et qui va mettre
ensemble 320 millions d'achats sur
lesquels on va faire 15% d'économie donc
45 millions d'économies sur 320 millions
c'est pas mal et on a un potentiel de 1
milliard d'achats possibles donc on n'a
pas besoin de la loi il suffit de nous
faciliter les choses pour nous permettre
de mettre en place une centrale d'achat
ce que je peux vous dire que c'est bien
compliqué avec la loi actuelle et que la
loi actuelle ne va pas le simplifier je
voudrais dire également que vous nous
avez dit prenez nous aux mots prenez
nous aux mots on vous tend la main pour
vous dire laissez-nous quelques mois et
on va vous proposer une carte simplement
j'ai remarqué que lorsque vous avez fini
vos propos vous avez que 8 collègues
dans l'assemblée qui ont applaudi vos
propos ce qui veut dire que quand même
vous n'avez pas tout à fait une majorité
qui vous suit dans vos propositions et
qui sont plutôt plus proche de ce que
nous proposons que ce que vous proposez
j'en suis désolé parce que c'est un bon
texte à condition que vous acceptiez de
nous suivre merci
l'amendement 105 est présenté par il y
en assassin
oui merci merci monsieur le Président de
me donner
la part Brest bref parce que beaucoup de
choses ont été dites faut pas dire il
faut dans le même temps je vous ai pas
beaucoup embêté
moi je trouve qu'on a eu un débat très
très intéressant mais aussi depuis ce
matin qui montre quand même une chose
importante à mes yeux en tout cas c'est
que toutes les réflexions qui ont été
émises depuis le début de la matinée ont
révélé que il n'y a aucun dogme
qui chapote toutes ces réflexions je
crois qu'on est beaucoup s'accordent
pour dire que ce texte va bouleverser le
paysage institutionnel dans notre pays
moi je voudrais dire pourquoi pas vous
le savez très bien nous sommes pour une
réforme nous sommes même nous allons
même au-delà puisque nous sommes
favorables à la construction populaire
j'oserais dire d'une sixième république
c'est pour dire que nous sommes
disponibles pour réformer mais il y a
aussi façon de réformer et donc
méthode parce qu'effectivement au bout
de plusieurs décennies rien de plus
normal qu'effectivement de vouloir
réformer mais il faut se poser les
bonnes questions c'est-à-dire pour faire
croire et au service de qui et parmi ces
questions cela va-t-il effectivement
produire des économies en la matière
avec le texte qui nous est proposé je
n'en suis pas sûr et en la matière je
pense qu'il faut que la forme ne peut
pas être déconnecté du fond la carte des
régions c'est un sujet c'est un vrai
sujet mais c'est ce n'est pas le sujet
comme le montre nos débats car
effectivement les les enjeux vont bien
au-delà quels seront les moyens donnés à
ces régions quelle autonomie fiscale
quelle pérennité et à ces questions
effectivement nous n'avons pas obtenu de
réponse et c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous demandons la suppression de cet
article je voulais revenir sur ce que
vous avez dit monsieur le ministre je
reconnais tout à fait vos talents
d'hommes politiques mais pour la clarté
des débats vous nous dites que dans le
texte dans le projet de loi il n'y a
rien sur la suppression des départements
alors dans le projet de loi en lui-même
oui mais alors quand on lit l'étude
d'impact vous savez celle que le
voilà et l'autre mais je m'en tiens à
celui-ci puisqu'on n'arrête pas de nous
dire qu'il faut parler de celui-ci alors
je vais m'arrêter sur celui-ci donc dans
l'étude d'impact page 30 précisément il
est écrit en effet avec l'augmentation
de la taille minimale des EPCI à
fiscalité propre à 1000 habitants la
recomposition de la carte régionale et
le transfert d'importants de compétences
des départements aux régions et aux EPCI
à fiscalité à fiscalité propre le
gouvernement met en place les conditions
nécessaires à la suppression des
départements en tant que collectivité
territoriale voilà c'est écrit dans
l'étude d'impact page 30 études d'impact
je vous rappelle qui a été validé par le
Conseil constitutionnel voilà après
cette petite
digression dans mon intervention sur le
premier j'ai quand même voulu assister
pour la faire pour que ce soit inscrit à
l'ordre du jour enfin au prochain verbal
de notre débat
très bien merci alors sur ces trois
abonnements monsieur le rapporteur
quelle est la vie de la Commission
monsieur le président
très sincèrement je suis dans le décor
le décor
écoutez les propos qui ont été changés
depuis plusieurs heures
j'ai essayé de suivre
48 pas que j'ai tout suivi
mais j'ai pris l'essentiel
et puis je suis de me souvenir de
la commission spéciale qui avait été
misée oui monsieur carucci
ça fait comme une campagne faite
ensemble ça laisse des souvenirs
des heures avoir votre profil d'où le
scepticisme
resplendissait
bref
on a avancé
on a même bien plutôt avancer de manière
satisfaisante monsieur le Président puis
l'article 1
puis des amendements pour supprimer
l'article
ces amendements j'étais pas pour
moi j'étais pour continuer
la commission spéciale a donné
marjoritairement un avis favorable à ses
amendements bon ben elle s'est trompé
c'est tout
mais ça veut pas dire pour autant
qu'elle a adopté ma position
elle a pris une position qui est contre
la vie du rapporteur du coup
puis l'article 1
et j'écoute depuis tout à l'heure les
interventions
vlatie pas comme on dit chez moi
vatica qui veulent tous refaire la carte
tous
j'ai pris les inscriptions
au fur et à mesure des débits assez à
commencer par le premier ministre
Jean-Pierre Raffarin
j'ai cru qu'il allait se lever
le Crillon à la main
et qu'il allait être suivi par une
longue théorie de sénateurs souhaitant
refaire la carte
ah si j'ai cru j'ai failli même me lever
moi-même
écoutez
vous voyez que la zone de risque était
pas loin
mais on était prêt quand j'ai écouté
plusieurs interventions d'ailleurs
plutôt de vos banques des banques
socialistes d'ailleurs bah ils avaient
pas de crayon à mon avis c'est tout bon
mais
j'étais impressionné si on se donnait je
me suis dit le temps
sur se donner le temps on refait cette
carte assez facilement
je dis pas monsieur le ministre qu'on
réglerait tous les problèmes
il en resterait il y aurait quelques
taches blanches mais une grande partie
des points qui ont pour certains déjà
été approchés dans la commission
spéciale trouverait à mon avis les voies
d'un règlement
donc moi je serais vous monsieur le
ministre nous laisserait la soirée
pour faire ça
en suspendrait maintenant
on suspendrait on ferait ça ah il y a le
problème il y a le match
bah il y a le match
ça va pas aider ça va pas aider
bon
non ça va pas aider non non l'idée est
bonne mais je la sens pas tellement
oh bah ce sera pour la seconde lecture
vous êtes tellement prêt à boucler cette
carte que ça devrait pas prendre un
temps fou Jean-Jacques caisse était déjà
prêt à s'y remettre lui
voilà donc
monsieur le Président j'en viens à ce
que j'avais à dire
la Commission ne m'a pas suivi elle a
voté les amendements qui
suppriment l'article 1 il faudra en
tirer les conséquences mais je peux pas
faire plus que ce que je viens de dire
merci de votre attention merci monsieur
le Président de la Commission m'avait
demandé intervenir
oui juridiquement il y a pas une demande
de renvoi en commission c'est le
Président la Commission s'est exprimée
par deux fois d'une part en élaborant
pas un texte c'est peut-être regrettable
sur l'article premier
en définitif s'il y avait eu que
l'article premier
dans le texte peut-être
pu évoluer mais il y a tout le reste qui
va avec et puis il y a le il y a le
deuxième projet et et je cite quand même
madame assassy a eu raison de citer
l'étude d'impact
nos collègues vous le savez très bien
monsieur le Président tout est ouvert à
condition qu'on supprime pas le
département et c'est même pas en zone
rurale pour certains c'est l'existence
même du département c'est pour ça que ça
bloquait c'est tout faut pas chercher
ailleurs que et après bien entendu
la Commission dans un premier temps
c'est vrai par amendement successifs et
par approche successifs parce que c'est
pas facile à mettre en place je vous
aurais souhaité bien du plaisir avec les
contradictions des amendements par quoi
commencer à quand on aboutissait c'est
quand même un travail en séance qui
n'est pas facile il faut le reconnaître
bon on l'avait fait en commission on
avait réussi à dire écoutez bon il y
avait des choses qu'on avait on avait
dit bon bah Poitou-Charentes Aquitaine
Limousin la Commission est d'accord
large accord pas beaucoup d'oppositions
mais par contre la Commission avait dit
m'excusé Alsace Lorraine
Champagne-Ardenne il y a des amandes
Alsace il boit je veux prête avec vous
bon rappelle
ensuite
Nord Pas de Calais Picardie parce qu'il
fait Picardie comme on les avait des
mariés avec la Champagne-Ardenne
enfin c'est pas exactement comme ça mais
enfin c'est un peu comme ça bon et puis
après Pays de Loire
centre
ah oui mais pays de loi Pays de Loire
dit nous on veut plutôt aller avec la
Bretagne parce que c'est comme ça
monsieur le ministre j'ai ce que tout ce
que j'ai entendu on a des mariés
Languedoc-Roussillon et Midi-Pyrénées
estiment que c'est des grosses régions
et que elles avaient quand même une
communauté de qui était pas évidente
comme ça sur tout un tas d'espèces c'est
comme ça bon et puis voilà alors on a
fait ce travail on a abouti ça provoqué
des réactions puisque beaucoup de
collègues sont exprimés d'ailleurs sur
tous les banques parce que aujourd'hui
certains mais hier j'en ai entendu
d'autres
oui bon alors monsieur le Président je
pense quand même que on ne peut pas en
plus les réactions quand on fait moi je
me sens en tant que parlementaire
capable de comprendre un certain nombre
de choses je connais pas trop mal le
territoire français j'essaie de
comprendre les solidarités les le fait
que en plus il faut tenir compte mais ça
moi j'en tiendrai jamais compte de ceux
qui sont en place et qui veulent pas
perdre leur place
est-ce que ça moi je n'aime pas les
potes en taloco je ne les ai jamais aimé
alors ça il faut quand même un jour dire
c'est pas ça l'important mais par contre
je pense que la carte honnêtement
n'avait un certain nombre de défauts
dont le principal était quand même cette
région
et alors en plus si on met pays de loi
avec Bretagne le centre est encore en
russe orphelin alors il y a deux
orphelins la Picardie elle sentent c'est
quand même dommage parce que sont des
belles régions voilà dans lequel
situation s'est trouvée monsieur le
Président mais je crois honnêtement
qu'on aurait pu proposer une carte même
si ça faisait pas plaisir à tout le
monde la commission s'il n'y avait eu
que ça
parce qu'on pourra le faire dans ce
cas-là en même temps des compétences et
de l'avenir des départements et à partir
de ce moment-là moi je suis convaincu
que le Sénat dans son rôle
constitutionnel saura faire une loi et
avec vous mais Monsieur le Ministre avec
vous une loi qui sera solide et qui sera
une loi d'avenir merci donc je poursuis
l'examen de ce texte quelle est la vie
du gouvernement sur le ministre
gouvernement il est favorable à cette
amendement pour les raisons que j'ai
évoquées tout à l'heure on nous explique
que cette carte pourrait être améliorée
que pour l'améliorer il faudrait la
supprimer en réécrire une autre
totalement et que pour ça il faudrait
prendre du temps prendre des mois
attendre encore attendre toujours nous
nous sommes dans un processus législatif
donc ce texte qui va partir après vers
une autre assemblée si vous ne le votez
pas et si vous supprimez ces articles
premiers nous n'allons pas attendre
encore et attendre toujours il y a une
navette parlementaire et un processus
législatif vous dit-il faut accepter la
main tendu mais nous la main étendue
depuis le début nous n'avons pas à faire
d'efforts pour l'attendre davantage vous
voulez une autre carte et bien amender
celle-ci et si ce qui est fait dans le
cadre de ce débat parlementaire n'est
pas suffisant il y aura d'autres
lectures il sera toujours temps
d'améliorer cette carte cette idée qu'il
faudrait arriver en seconde lecture avec
une
une page blanche et que l'été aidant les
esprits aurai mûri et que la meilleure
des cartes serait possible et quand même
une manière de nous dire à nous membres
du gouvernement que nous sommes
suffisamment stupides pour ne pas
l'avoir trouvé nous-mêmes que l'exercice
suffisamment facile pour qu'il suffisent
d'un été pour le réussir tout cela vous
le savez beaucoup plus compliqué que
cela donc si vous considérez qu'il faut
une autre carte commencez à la modifier
maintenant il y aura d'autres
discussions il y aura d'autres occasions
d'échanges vous tendez une main en
disant modifiant cette carte je la
prends volontiers en vous proposant que
l'on commence tout de suite vous nous
dites il faut du temps pour aller au
bout des choses le temps de la navette
parlementaire nous permettra d'aller au
bout des choses et vous souvenez
d'ailleurs qu'à certains nombre de
textes qui ont été décidés du jour au
lendemain et qui avait des conséquences
extraordinairement lourdes pour les
collectivités locales je pense à la
suppression de la carte professionnelle
de la carte de la taxe professionnelle
avait fait l'objet
une discussion préalable que ces textes
ont été totalement réécris au Parlement
dans les conditions que l'on sait qu'à
ce moment là ça n'a suscité aucune
émotion sur les bancs de l'opposition et
que vous n'avez pas demandé que les
départs que l'automne passe que l'hiver
passe et pourtant nous étions sur des
sujets beaucoup plus tectoniques que
ceux dont nous parlons aujourd'hui donc
je vous propose de prendre la main que
vous tendez de commencer le travail de
le poursuivre tout au long de la navette
parlementaire et de le faire sans perdre
de temps c'est la raison pour laquelle
je ne suis pas favorable à cet amende
merci Monsieur le Ministre bien alors à
l'explication de vote Michel Boutin
oui monsieur le Président je ne voterai
pas cet amendement pour plusieurs
raisons la première c'est que nos
collègues de l'opposition nous disent
mais
il faut se mettre au travail pour
redessiner mais je veux dire sur un
certain nombre de territoires mes chers
collègues
ce travail nous l'avons déjà fait nous
l'avons même entamé dès le 2 juin le
soir ou le jour où a été annoncé cette
carte
et nous l'avons fait à partir de la base
et vous nous dites aujourd'hui c'est à
partir de là qu'il faut partir et si
aujourd'hui le président de la
commission des lois nous dit que sur
cette région qui appelle tant et tant de
remarques qui est la région Centre
Poitou-Charentes Limousin la commission
des lois a voté une très large majorité
la proposition d'un amendement qui vise
à ce qu'elle soit modifiée pour en faire
une région Aquitaine Poitou-Charentes
Limousin je suis prêt à penser que ce
travail qui a été engagé dès le 3 juin
et nous ne sommes pas toujours en
parlotte à repousser à
en internement en
délai supplémentaire que vous que vous
demandez il faut savoir à un moment ou à
un autre s'investir pleinement mes chers
collègues dans des dans des
contre-propositions et si elles doivent
partir de la base nous avons trouvé là
justement dans la région
Poitou-Charentes et au-delà et au-delà
des clivages politiques puisque je le
disais hier dans mon intervention les
quatre conseils généraux des quatre
départements de la région
Poitou-Charentes se sont réunis et ont
assisté à cette réunion également les
parlementaires qui pouvaient se libérer
ce jour-là il y a eu un vote sur les 160
et quelques conseillers généraux
présents il y a eu une voix contre la
proposition Aquitaine Poitou-Charente
Limousin deux abstentions tous les
autres étaient favorables je pense et je
pense que cette décision ajoutée aux
délibérations qui remontent des communes
de ces régions qui vont toutes dans le
même dans le même sens je pense que là
nous avons entamé ce travail dont on ne
sait pas aujourd'hui par quel bout
exactement il faut le prendre s'il va
être parlementaire s'il va être local
mais prenez les initiatives il s'agit
aujourd'hui de définir un terrain sur
lequel demain
demain nous devrons reprendre nos
combats politiques mais là ça dépasse
les clivages en quelque sorte c'est
toujours ce que j'ai dit il s'agit de
définir le terrain sur lequel nous
allons évoluer et d'ailleurs je crois
que ce message là il a été compris que
ce soit par Dominique Bussereau
président du conseil général de
Charente-Maritime Claude Berto président
du conseil général
UMP de la Vienne ou bien Éric Gauthier
président du conseil général des
Deux-Sèvres ou par moi-même il y a un
moment il faut savoir dépasser pour
faire des propositions et ensuite le jeu
politique reprend son cours
merci d'abord l'état Vincent Delahaye
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre j'écoute depuis ce matin
attentivement l'ensemble des
interventions et beaucoup vont dans le
même sens
je voudrais pour ma part répondre à
quelques éléments de réponse qui a
apporté monsieur le ministre tout à
l'heure en disant il faut réformer c'est
urgent tout le monde demande des
réformes et nous au groupe nous
sommes favorables aux réforme
structurelles et aux réforme de fonds
puisqu'il y en a beaucoup à mener et que
depuis deux ans nous en avons finalement
vu que très peu et c'est là où je pense
que nous avons perdu beaucoup de temps
il y a la réforme de la fiscalité il y a
la réforme du droit du travail il y a la
réforme du coût du travail à la réforme
des retraites et la réforme de la
demisation chômage il y a plein de
réformes à faire en France le
millefeuille territorial fait partie de
ces réformes le gouvernement en début
d'année subitement a décidé
qu'effectivement il fallait réformer le
millefeuille territorial quel est le
problème du millefeuille territorial
quel est le problème en tout cas perçu
par les Français de ce millefeuille
territorial c'est qu'il y a plusieurs
niveaux d'intervention il y a les
communes les départements les interco
les départements les régions la France
l'État
excusez-moi mes chers collègues mais je
considère qu'il y a un problème de
lisibilité qui est perçu par les
Français et un problème d'efficacité et
de coût
et ce problème c'est un problème
d'ensemble et le gouvernement a supprimé
ce qui avait été à rétabli plutôt ce qui
avait été supprimé c'est la clause de
compétence générale qui fait que
plusieurs collectivités peuvent
intervenir sur le même sujet je pense
que ça c'est un facteur de dépenses et
de coûts et d'inification dans notre
système du millefeuille territorial donc
moi je suis d'accord pour que l'on
réforme ce mille-feuille simplement
derrière il y a un problème de méthode
parce que finalement on s'aperçoit que
cette réforme qu'est-ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui c'est une carte on est en
train de discuter de la carte et de se
dire il faudrait qu'on décide nous ici
au Sénat la carte que le Président de la
République a décidé à l'Elysée en
prenant l'avis d'un quelques amis et
qu'il a finalement décidé d’apposer par
le haut je pense que nous avons un
problème de méthode de réforme en France
il faudrait enfin nous devenions une
démocratie un peu adulte et prenons
exemple sur les pays nordiques ils
sautent en recherche de consensus les
pays nordiques quand ils réforme et
comment ça se passe comment ça se passe
tomber sur la table un texte un texte
d'ensemble avec les compétences les
niveaux les niveaux de responsabilité et
on le met en discussion dans le pays
avec l'ensemble des élus avec les
habitants avec tous ceux qui veulent
sans saisir et au bout de d'un certain
nombre de temps que fixe le gouvernement
on arrête le débat on fait une synthèse
et ensuite le gouvernement effectivement
prend ses responsabilités et propose un
texte et non pas quelque chose qui
débarque d'un seul coup qui surprend un
peu tout le monde et puis qu'on nous dit
vous avez en urgence le devoir d'établir
cette carte à toute vitesse moi je pense
que la méthode est mauvaise et c'est
pour ça que nous n'arrivons pas à nous
mettre d'accord n'arrivons pas à nous
mettre d'accord parce que le débat n'a
pas eu lieu et que le débat finalement
il a lieu la rapidement entre nous et on
s'aperçoit bien que bien sûr c'est pas
simple mais que finalement sur le fond
nous n'avons pas assez d'éléments pour
nous prononcer donc au groupe udi c'est
vrai que nous sommes très embêtés parce
que nous avons envie de montrer que nous
sommes favorables pour aller de l'avant
et pour faire bouger les choses et en
même temps on sent bien que le texte qui
nous est présenté aujourd'hui et
vraiment insuffisant il est carrément
insuffisant donc
c'est compliqué c'est vrai qu'on s'est
beaucoup interrogé et finalement nous
souhaitons nous sommes attachés bien sûr
au Sénat nous sommes attachés au rôle du
Sénat et nous sommes embêtés que le
Sénat assez souvent finalement présente
une copie blanche on arrive souvent à se
mettre d'accord contre les textes on a
beaucoup plus de mal à se mettre
d'accord pour un texte et ça c'est quand
même une problématique donc c'est vrai
qu'on s'est dit au niveau du groupe EDI
on a fini par décider globalement et
majoritairement de dire nous allons
accorder sa chance à discussion au Sénat
et donc nous ne voterons pas ces notions
même si nous comprenons les motifs qui
ont présidé à leur dépôt amendement
pardon
merci rogerucci à la parole
monsieur le ministre moi je comprends
très bien après tout c'est comme ça il y
a un gouvernement vous voulez réformer
vous voulez reporter les élections vous
arrivez avec un texte
ce texte soyons francs on a bien vu au
travers y compris d'amendements
socialiste pendant le débat de la
commission spéciale ce texte il est
évolutif
mais il est d'autant plus évolutif qu'on
a le sentiment que la détermination ou
les options du gouvernement ne sont pas
définitivement stabilisés
ne sont pas définitivement stabilisés
sur le sort des départements
sur les compétences ne sont pas
définitivement stabilisés sur les moyens
financiers
et donc sincèrement vous vous tournez
vers l'opposition mais aussi vers la
majorité pour dire il y a une carte
forcément moi je dis pas le contraire on
arrive avec une carte bah elle est un
peu par définition pas très stabilisée
parce que toute carte peut être faite
mais Monsieur le Ministre quand le
Premier ministre Raffarin vous dit
on vous tend la main bien sûr on sait
bien que en votant la suppression de
l'article 1 il y a plus de cartes et on
renvoie vers l'assemblée
un article sans carte mais en réalité on
sait bien que l'assemblée va voter soit
la carte que vous allez présenter soit
autre chose la seule chose que l'on vous
demande c'est non pas d'empêcher
l'assemblée de faire elle va faire mais
on vous dit monsieur le ministre vous
allez revenir au mois d'octobre avec le
deuxième texte celui sur les compétences
celui sur les moyens probablement d'ici
là le gouvernement lui-même aura
réfléchi avec le groupe socialiste sur
ce qu'on fait des départements puisqu'on
voit bien que même dans le groupe
socialiste ça évolue sur ce qu'on veut
faire des départements à ce moment-là
monsieur le ministre on aura plus
d'éléments nous-mêmes en main qu'est-ce
que vous faites des départements on le
saura peut-être plus et davantage
ensemble qu'est-ce que vous donnez comme
compétence région on le saura à ce
moment-là probablement plus qu'est-ce
que vous donnez comme moyen on le saura
à ce moment-là tous ensemble gauche et
droite davantage
et à ce moment là Monsieur le Ministre
ce qu'on vous demande c'est non pas de
ne pas aller à l'Assemblée c'est de
revenir en deuxième lecture ici en
disant voilà mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs le gouvernement a évolué sur
le sort des départements le gouvernement
a stabilisé la manière dont il voit les
compétences des régions et des
départements le gouvernement sait quels
sont les moyens maintenant mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs quel que soit la
carte
issue de l'Assemblée peut-être un peu
rapidement au mois de juillet
réfléchissez travailler sur une carte
des régions qui soient fondées sur le
sort des départements sur les
compétences et sur les moyens qui plus
est monsieur le ministre nous aurons
tous chacune et chacun dans nos régions
rencontrer les élus locaux vu les études
vu les sondages rencontrer les acteurs
économiques et on aura évidemment une
vision de ce que nos propres acteurs
politiques économiques sociaux souhaite
davantage avec des précisions de votre
part sur le sort des départements sur
les compétences sur les moyens le fait
qu'on aura nous-mêmes rencontré
davantage d'ici le mois d'octobre les
acteurs politiques économiques et
sociaux on sera plus à même comme le
propose le Premier ministre à Farin de
vous dire ok on peut travailler sur une
carte et vous faire une proposition et
après on travaille ensemble sincèrement
ça m'est arrivé dans le passé et ça
arrivera à quiconque et à quelconque
gouvernement travailler avec l'Assemblée
qui représente les collectivités
territoriales c'est quand même ce qu'il
y a de mieux pour refaire la carte de
France pour les 50 ans qui viennent
préciser la pensée du Gouvernement sur
ce qui va devenir des départements des
compétences des moyens aller à
l'Assemblée revenez au Sénat en octobre
avec les deux textes et faites confiance
au Sénat gauche et droite confondues
pour faire le texte et la carte moi ce
que je vous demande c'est pas de nous
dire que vous êtes pour la suppression
de l'article vous ne pouvez évidemment
pas dire ça tout ce que je vous demande
monsieur le ministre c'est de dire au
Premier ministre à Farin oui quoi qu'il
advienne à l'Assemblée le gouvernement
ayant précisé sa pensée sur le sort des
collectivités les moyens et les
compétences nous reviendrons au Sénat
avec l'esprit ouvert pour faire ensemble
la nouvelle carte merci la parole est à
Jacqueline Gourault
mon collègue
Vincent vient de préciser la position
largement majoritaire du groupe à savoir
que nous ne voterons pas la suppression
de l'article 1 je voudrais rappeler
comme je l'ai déjà fait
au début de je ne sais plus ces jours
depuis que nous sommes ici nous n'avons
pas bougé
que bien sûr ceci ne veut pas dire que
nous sommes d'accord avec ce qu'il y a
dans ce texte et que dès le départ j'ai
pris soin de dire que la carte ne nous
convenait pas
par ailleurs
je crois au fil de ces discussions avoir
compris aussi
messieurs les ministres que peut-être
vous avez
comment dire insuffisamment communiqué
avec un certain nombre d'élus
régionaux avec un certain nombre de
personnalités
qui auraient mérité d'être consulté je
crois que c'est une erreur et c'est vrai
qu'on a eu le sentiment dans la manière
dont cette carte a été faite que
seulement quelques grandes personnalités
de gauche et du Parti socialiste avait
eu droit à la parole et avait donné lieu
à une carte qui pour nous est
catastrophique bien
je voulais rappeler cela alors ceci dit
voilà nous quittons l'hémicycle du Sénat
sachez bien que